10 o'clock i'd call this meeting as the
public works and highways committee to
order
as chair of the house public works and
highway community i find that through
the state of emergency
declared
number 12 pursuant to executive order
2020-04
this public body is authorized to meet
electronically
this is a public hearing on senate bills
referred to this community with
potential for executive sessions to be
held throughout the day
please know that there is no physical
location for members of the public to
observe
and listen contemporaneously to this
meeting
however in accordance with the emergency
order i am confirming that
all members of the committee and select
legislative staff have the ability to
communicate contemporaneously during
this meeting through the zoom electronic
meeting platform
and that the public has access it can
have
contemporaneously listened
and if necessary participate in this
meeting via the zoom platform or by
teleport
all necessary access information has
been
made available in the house calendar and
through the electronic calendar on the
german court website
the notice for this meeting
uh complies with house rules and rsa
91-8
anyone who has a problem accessing the
meeting should call
271-3600
or email
hcs
at leg
in the event the public is unable to
access the meeting the meeting will be
adjourned and rescheduled
i want to introduce the staff that are
meeting with us and assisting
brad greenland committee researcher and
christopher shea
please note that all votes that are
taken during this meeting shall be done
by roll call vote
let us start the meeting by taking your
roll call attendance when each member
states their present please also state
whether there is anyone in the room with
you during this meeting which is
required under the right to know
mr clerk
thank you mr chairman
representative abbott
here in the committee room
representative post
i am at my home and my husband is here
thank you representative boards
representative boards
representative bunker
president um alone in my home office
thank you representative clutier uh here
president in the committee room
representative grassy
i'm here at home and my wife is in the
house as well
representative evil
home alone in new london
representative edgar
president
home alone in hampton
representative faulkner
i am home in swansea and my wife is in
the other room
representative phil dolphy
i'm here
in hillsborough
i'm temporarily alone
representative graham
i'm here in the committee room in
concord
representative jack
representative kaczynski
representative kolansky
representative mcconkey
president here in the committee room
representative mills is here and taking
attendance
representative newman
yes present at home in nashua my husband
is in the house
representative newton yes i'm home in
rochester my wife is in the house
representative peterson
just was there
representative query
present at home in manchester alone
representative samara
i am here in a hotel room in florida
yeah that's me giving you the stink guy
representative thompson
president of the committee road
representative boyd
representative boyd here in merrimack my
daughter is in her bedroom of sleep
welcome
thank you i'll give the representative
peterson one more shot representative
peterson
i saw him here a minute ago he was here
yeah
we'll catch we'll see if we'll catch him
later he's on the screen
all right thank you mr clerk
and there is foreign president um i
would ask uh
that we open the hearing on
senate bill 28 naming the courtroom in
the second circuit courthouse in
plymouth in honor of judge edwin w kelly
and i would call on the prime sponsor
senator gaida to introduce the bill
thank you mr chairman honourable members
of the committee
i'm here today to introduce my senate
bill 28
for the record
senator bob gaida district 2.
this bill names a courtroom in the
second circuit courthouse in plymouth
one of the towns in my district in honor
of judge edwin w kelly
i was contacted by senior judge tom
rappa who wanted to recognize more than
30 years of service that judge kelly has
given to our state and its people
judge kelly recently retired
and but he served both the state of new
hampshire and our judicial system with
distinction
he has garnered wide praise throughout
the plymouth area and legal communities
across the state for his demeanor his
fairness and his knowledge of the law
some of his accomplishments include
helping to create the family division
within the court system
and working on bail reform
uh most notably judge kelly helped
create the circuit court in 2011 which
then chief justice robert lynn noted was
quote a herculean task end quote
throughout his various roles in the
judicial system judge kelly has left an
indelible mark and earned the respect of
staff judges and other stakeholders at
the court
he helped define the role of an
administrative judge in responding to
citizens and other stakeholders who had
less than positive experiences within
the judicial system
i believe judge kelly exhibits all the
attributes that one would look for in a
great judge
i hope the committee will look favorably
upon this bill and vote the bill ought
to pass
thank you representative graham and
members of the committee
can i take any questions questions of
senator gutter
seeing none i would
ask that
representative gordon be brought forward
to
testify
welcome representative
representative gordon i i say that
you're still muted
thank you thank you
chairman graham members of the committee
thank you for your patience
i also uh speak in favor of uh senate
bill 28 and naming the courtroom after
judge kelly
i served under him as a circuit court
judge for many years
but even before i was a judge he was the
administrative judge of the court
and i saw the court evolve over many
years
when i first started practicing law
the
the circuit court and particularly the
district court
was uh
uh at at best uh disheveled it was uh
basically made up of part-time judges
all over the state
and if you were a practicing attorney
it depended on what court you went to
what judge you saw in order the type of
law you were going to type a judgment or
law you were going to receive
and when judge kelly was appointed the
administrative judge
he did a number of things he
standardized practices
he made it so that we had
full-time judges judges who wanted to be
judges
who weren't doing that just to build
their resume but because they wanted to
do it as a career
and that was a huge improvement
senator guide has also mentioned some of
the other things that he's done
such as adopting the family court where
we actually had family court judges who
wanted to do family court cases
which was a change
uh he also
prospered the court in the sense that he
saw that we had new courtrooms
new courthouses built across the state
and we weren't having
our courts held in places like in
franklin where you did it in the old
opera house on the theater
the uh
he um he's done a great deal to prosper
the court uh and uh probably the one of
the most important things he did was uh
among the last things he did and that
was to do bring it bring the court into
uh the 21st century electronically so
that people could electronically file
and people did not have to
go through the
the formal process
of appearing for everything that needs
to be done
and in short i i can't think of anyone
who was more worthy of having a
courtroom named after him frankly
in my personal opinion i think the
courthouse in plymouth ought to be named
after him
uh but uh naming a courtroom uh
certainly would be an honor and i
certainly would encourage you to do so
thank you
questions uh representation for
seeing um thank you
um
if we can bring um
thomas rapper
thomas wrap
hey
there okay whenever you're ready
good morning uh
mr chairman and members of the committee
uh thank you for allowing me to speak
here today
in support of senate bill 28
naming the primary courtroom of the
plymouth circuit courthouse
to commemorate the remarkable career of
the honorable edwin w kelly
i've had the distinct honor of serving
as a judge in the district and now
circuit court for over 32 years
and most of that time
for over two decades i sat
in the very courthouse that is subject
to this bill
this afforded me not only an opportunity
to work closely with judge kelly but
also to observe him as he carried out
many of his other duties as
administrative judge
i urge you to support this bill for the
simple reason
that judge kelly has earned this
recognition based on his contributions
to the people of new hampshire
as the first administrative judge
of what was the district and municipal
court and is now the circuit court
over the two and a half decades that
judge kelly served in that role he
defined the position
as he guided the court into the modern
era
in my humble opinion
as new hampshire's first administrative
judge of the circuit court
edwin w kelly did more to provide fair
and efficient access to justice
for the citizens of new hampshire than
any other individual who's ever served
in the judicial system
given my limited time here today
i'm not
able to specifically enumerate
the long list of major accomplishments
uh that judge kelly was able to
achieve during his tenure
but let me summarize by saying that
through his steadfast commitment to the
people in new hampshire
he made the court more efficient
saving the citizens of new hampshire
literally hundreds of thousands of
dollars each year
through his tireless efforts and
eloquent advocacy
he created consistent processes and
procedures
that gave a voice to many who had no
prior voice in the system
such as victims of domestic violence and
child abuse
through his effective leadership he
modernized the court system and help
motivate others to create a judicial
system here in new hampshire
that is renowned nationwide for its
fairness and
progressive
processes
a court
system that is now respected
uh across this country
judge kelly is a great man
he's an outstanding judge and he is an
inspiring leader
we the citizens of new hampshire owe him
our highest respect
and
sincere gratitude for his outstanding
service
and significant contributions to the new
hampshire judicial system
candidly i agree with uh
representative gordon
i believe the whole courthouse should be
named in honor of judge kelly
but naming the primary courtroom where
he
served as the first judge in that
courtroom
is the least we can do and i implore you
to pass this bill
and create a lasting symbol of our
appreciation for judge kelly's
remarkable career
and the amazing amazing impact he has
had on the new hampshire judicial system
thank you very much
thank you joe uh are there any questions
for
seeing none thank you
and you can hear from the honorable
junior earlier
welcome once again to public works
thank you
thank you uh honorable chairman graham
and members of public works and highways
i'm virginia irwin and a former member
of this august committee uh it's nice to
be with you again even though we're uh
sort of the distances but it's nice to
see your faces
um i'm i'm here because i want to uh
support senate bill 28 as amended and
i'm not sure if the amendment has been
introduced yet
i would uh respectfully wait until it
has been introduced mr chairman okay
thank you thank you very much and uh
uh marsha singh
bring her up
jack
good morning um my name is um
good morning uh chairman and members of
the committee uh can you hear me okay
yes
great um my name is marcia sink and i am
the ceo of casa of new hampshire a
statewide guardian at litum program
and i'm here in support of senate bill
28 and actually
honored and delighted to be able to
testify
in support of this bill
judge kelly um is a remarkable man as
has has been shared already in previous
testimony uh from representative gordon
and judge rappa
um he was instrumental back in 1989
when casa was first introduced to the
state
as an organization that would support
children and families who are involved
in child abuse and neglect
hearings
with a casa volunteer
to serve in the role of guardian at
lightham
i have to say if it had not been for
judge kelly's support
and continued guidance as the
organization developed and grew
i'm not sure we would be where we are
today with over 600 volunteer advocates
in every courtroom
family and circuit courtrooms throughout
the state of new hampshire
judge kelly in addition to all his other
attributes that have been
shared and his ability in in his
administrative position
has had a commitment to new hampshire's
children and families that has just been
outstanding
he was accessible always um to to me and
to others he was
flexible and
always interested in
exploring new ways that we could improve
our
system
and how we were managing these cases of
abuse and neglect uh throughout the
state
uh i have to say his fairness uh he was
sitting part-time
in the plymouth court when casa first
started and his fairness and judicial
temperament was outstanding and he
carried that with him into his role in
the administration of of all of the
circuit and family courts throughout the
state so i just really wanted to be here
this morning um to
support this bill the entire casa
organization is supportive of passing
senate bill 28 and in fact i would be uh
agree with
judge rappa and
judge gordon in their support of naming
the courthouse um in his honor but at
the very least this courtroom in the
plymouth court should be
a lasting
memorial to his outstanding outstanding
work on behalf of so many of new
hampshire's citizens so thank you for
the opportunity
are there any questions i'm missing
seeing them thank you very much
and with that i see no other
um people wish to testify on senate bill
um
28 i will close the hearing on senate
bill 28 and open the public hearing on
our non-germane amendment to senate bill
which names a roundabout in the town of
new london in order of jesse levine and
i call on the
sponsor of the amendment representative
evil
thank you very much mr chair and members
of the committee for the record my name
is karen ebel and i represent merrimack
district 5 new london and newbury and
i'm here to introduce this morning um
amendment number 2021 hyphen 1-1
1-2 h
and as the chairman mentioned this
amendment to sb 28 would name the
roundabout at the intersection of
newport road and
county road in new london
for jesse levine
and just as a preliminary
matter for the committee
i believe our town administrator has
forwarded to you
a
a letter indicating the support of new
london's board of selectmen for this um
this
naming bill which i know is a
prerequisite for
the committee to uh move ahead um in its
discretion
um
i'd like to say several words about
jesse levine um
and why i have introduced this um this
amendment
jessie is a new hampshire native she was
born and raised in hopkinton new
hampshire
she's a graduate of hopkinton
high school she went to dartmouth
college and she has a graduate degree in
public administration from unh
she spent her whole life in new
hampshire but for a brief time in boston
and then she came back up here
throughout her career she's been
dedicated to municipal and county
government
i got to know jesse during her 11-year
tenure at new as new london's town
manager when i was also on the planning
board
and anybody who has been on a planning
board or in local government knows that
there can be many challenges
and
among those challenges was
how to resolve a traffic issue at the
intersection of
county road and newport road
um
at the time that she suggested putting a
roundabout there it was a very
controversial
um issue
roundabouts really weren't uh
well thought of across the board as
opposed to traffic lights or just
sitting at a stop sign
but her um recommendation was innovative
and bold for the time and she uh saw the
future and she worked very hard to bring
it to fruition in the town of new london
and i think
even though for those people that live
in more urban areas
the backups might be uh not so much for
us it was a great uh a great thing so we
appreciated her efforts
um after new london she was assistant
town manager in hanover she was the town
manager in
bedford and she ultimately served as the
sullivan county manager
she had to retire early
after about a year when she was
diagnosed with als at age 45 which
was tragic needless to say
during her stellar career she was
identified as a rising star in the union
union leaders 40 under 40. she was the
past president of the municipal
management association she was active in
the new hampshire municipal association
she was recognized as county manager of
the year in 2016. she was a low leader
in rotary
and in 2017 she received the raymond s
burton public service award
jessie turns 51
shortly she's battled als valiantly as
she has fought for the good
not only of the citizens of our
town but for the region
and for the state
at every opportunity that she could
i'd like to just read a couple of words
that she wrote uh when she was nominated
for 40 under 40 for the union leader
local government is bottom up democratic
innovative proactive responsive
accessible flexible accountable
social careful caring measurable and
effective
local government exists to serve the
needs and improve the quality of life
for those who live within its boundaries
and even though change can be slow at
times the rewards are worth the effort
the hardest days are often from
a mentality that it's always been done
jessie was an innovator she was
enthusiastic energetic she was
a model citizen of the state of new
hampshire
and i would appreciate your support
of this legislation to name the
roundabout
in new london for jesse levine thank you
any questions from the committee for
uh representative eagle
seeing that
i would call upon representative clute
either
you want me to
[Music]
i rise with strong support of this
amendment to senate bill 28 through
naming roundabout
in london in honor of jesse levine and
although the roundabout is not in
sullivan county although assists down
the road i think it's an appropriate
honor
for jessie because i worked with her
in some of my previous terms as
delegation chair
she was very innovative she helped
acquire more land uh vicinity where a
lot of our county landed and as a result
of those efforts we turned that that
area
into a recreational area the benefits of
all of our conscious citizens
that's an achievement
that it was you know like no other
problem did
so i found to be very energetic
innovative and up to the challenges of
trying to manage in small rural counties
and i want to say in conclusion that
when your time is done that you have to
leave early because of declining health
[Music]
probably made the smoothest transition
to a county manager that i have ever
seen before since i've been a member of
sultan county delegate so he urges me
to adopt
an entertainment
2 h the centerfield 28 has passed the
entire senate bill
thank you
any questions of representative clutier
from the committee
team
and now
once again the honorable
uh virginia irwin
again welcome back to public works thank
you mr chairman and members of the
committee
i am a former member of this august
committee and it is nice to see you all
again uh and i'm here to support the
amendment proffered by representative
ebel to name the roundabout in new
london after jesse levine i can think of
no one better to honor
than jesse with this dedication
and this location
jesse was an administrator for the town
of newport uh for the town of new london
rather and for many years and then she
eventually came to be the administrator
in sullivan county
as the county manager she worked closely
with the delegation to move the county
forward
to improve services and to streamline
operations
to quote william shakespeare though she
but but belittle she is fierce
if you know me she bested me by an inch
jessie is fierce and passionate
she always did what was best for the
town and for the county
even if it wasn't popular and it might
have ruffled a few feathers
she is fierce in her fight against als
and in its infancy
it never stopped her from doing her job
she is fierce in how she handles
adversity
i know this dedication will mean a lot
to her and to her family to know how
much we admire respect and love her for
her dedication and devotion to our
communities
so i urge you to vote yes on this
amendment and i thank you for taking my
testimony and once again it's nice to
see you all again
are there any questions of
the honorable former member
you're getting that way
thank
you see none
that is the last person i have signed up
are there any
uh
members representatives
cliff
yeah i'm uh i'm having trouble hearing
the testimony uh the question is i do
not have a copy of the amendment in
front of me
i'm having trouble getting the
information from this committee i don't
know i i checked into it with leadership
yesterday
and i found out it may be going to an
email that hasn't been activated i get
notices of other things
but i do not have the amendment could
you could somebody from the committee
explain to me exactly what this
amendment does in that
does it replace
uh the existing wording in senate bill
28 or does it just add
and if it's not lengthy could it could
it be possible that the amendment be
read so those of us on the committee
that are going to have to vote for it
know what we're voting for
now a couple of things
did you get your email situation fixed
with uh house leadership and i.t
uh no actually they sent me a link to
the create a
a
password which i created a password and
sent it and it went into oblivion so
i'm pretty sure what's going to have to
happen is they're going to have to hold
my hand
through the process i will read
the amendment
um it does not replace
the first part which is about
uh naming the uh
room in the uh second court the
courthouse employment
uh it has a section of jesse we're being
rounded up the pursuant rsa 4-43
the roundabout located at new hampshire
route 11 also known as the u.s section
of newport road and county road in the
town of new london
is hereby named the jesse were being
bound about
this one county government leader and
new london resident jesse w levine
among her many career achievements in
the pursuit of good local government ms
levine advocated for and oversaw the
roundabout construction while serving as
new london's town administrator
an appropriate market may be placed on
the center island at the roundabout then
signage the cost of design constructs
maintenance installation of any signage
replacement signage or other markers
authorized under section two of this act
shall not be as charged to the same
however the design construction
installation of any signings or other
markets authorized shall be approved by
the department of transportation
thank you mr chairman
no problem
representative evil
yes thank you mr chairman i've had a
communication from
kim hallquist who is the town
administrator for new london
that she's here and
wanted to testify i asked her to raise
her hand
on zoom i don't know if the
uh tech folks see her but she is here
and she would like to testify
go ahead
good morning uh chairman graham and
members of the committee and especially
representative evil who represents new
london so well i couldn't agree more
with all of the comments
previous to mine about jesse levine
the town of new london enthusiastically
supports this bill to name the new
london roundabout the jesse levine
roundabout
this will make official what has been
the common understanding of new london
new londoners since even before the
roundabout was open townspeople have
referred to it as the jesse levine
roundabout because of her dogged support
of the project in her belief not held by
all that the roundabout would increase
the safety of citizens traveling on
newport and county roads
townspeople saw jesse as a leader of
what was at first a very controversial
project many had never heard about
roundabouts and many feared chaos and
mayhem would result if it was ever built
jesse addressed all of these concerns
with patience and good humor until there
was enough support to get funding for
the project
now more than 10 years after the
roundabout open even the detractors
admit that the roundabout is a big
success
this is thanks to the efforts of many
but in particular jesse levine who just
wouldn't give up on getting something
that was virtually unheard of at the
time built in new london
we can't think of a better way to
recognize jesse's efforts than naming
the roundabout in her honor
thank you very much
are there any questions from the members
of the committee
see none thank you
anyone else
so raise your electronic can
i will close the meeting on
uh the amendment to senate bill 28 28
and open up the executive session on
senate bill 28 and the non-janine
amendment
i recognize representative evil for a
motion
thank you very much mr chair
for all the reasons that we've heard
already um i would
like to move and it is my honor to move
um amendment 11182h
to sb
for passage
was moved
acceptance of
the amendment
represented mcconkey seconds
for any discussion
on the amendment
so raise your hand let me know
saying none of the clerk call the roll
thank you mr
chair representative mcconkey aye
clerk both yes
representative sumero
i vote yes
representative fedorfi
yes representative newton
yes
representative post
representative boards
representative kaczynski
representative kolansky
representative thompson
yes
representative boyd
lloyd votes i
representative cluedia yes
representative edgar all right
representative evil
yes
representative martin
i'm sorry representative jack
representative abbott yes
representative faulkner yes
representative newman
yes
representative grassy
representative peterson
yes
representative query
representative bunker
yes
and the
chairman graham
full disclosure i have known jesse since
she was the uh town manager in bedford
and my wife did go to graduate school
with her but i do love this
thank you mr chair the vote is 20-0 in
favor of the octopass amendment
thank you
our representative
recognized representative evil for
another motion
um first of all i just really want to
thank the committee for its support of
the amendment it means a lot to
the town and i know to jesse in
particular who's watching with us today
thank you
i would now like to move uh ought to
pass on sb
28 as amended which would name the
second circuit courthouse courtroom for
the honorable judge edwin kelly
who has been
a model judge for all of us
and i'd appreciate your support for it
thank you
representative evil moves out to pass
with amendment
representative mcconkey seconds
promotion
for any discussion
raise your hand say none
representative mcconkey aye
clerk votes yes
representative samara
samaro votes yes
representative phidolfi
yes
representative newton
representative post
yes
representative boards
representative kaczynski
representative kolansky
representative thompson yes
representative boyd
lloyd voted
representative clutier yes
representative edgar
aye
representative ebel
yes
representative jack
representative abbott yes
representative faulkner
yes
representative newman
representative grassy
yes
representative peterson
representative query
yes
representative bunker
chairman graham yes
mr chair to vote is 20-0 in favor of
ought to pass as amended thank you
well we usually don't do this for naming
bills is there any objection to consent
no mr chairman
all right
same calendar will be i closed the
executive session on senate bill
28 and we have about three minutes
before we hear senate bill 32.
is
okay
[Music]
as you remember no that's fine i my i'm
in north carolina and the internet is
spotty so forgive me
that's okay i'd rather be on the outer
banks myself
watch
the time being 10 45
i will open the hearing on senate bill
and act relative to the fallen state
troopers memorial and call upon the
prime sponsor senator burnsville
thank you mr chair and thank you
committee for hearing senate bill
um 32
i just want to um for the record my name
is regina burtsell i'm state senator for
district 19 winching which encompasses
the towns of derry hampstead in windham
and i'm here as the prime sponsor of
senate bill 32 which is
the relative to the fallen state
troopers memorial if this is actually a
very simple bill back in
we passed senate bill 300 which was an
act naming us
um
[Music]
sorry um
this the memorial will honor all the
troopers who have fallen in line of duty
since the state police was create sorry
was created in 1937.
i want to express my thanks to the men
men and women in this police force they
are probably the best trained in the
country
and what this bill will do is like i
said it will honor the troops but also
what it does is street it's going to
streamline the process that allows the
memorial committee
to disperse the private funds without
having to continuously go to the
governor and the executive council
um
what what happens right now is because
because many of the the memorial
uh the memorial is going to have a
number of contractors so rather than
having to have each piece that each
contractor is working on to go to the
executive council
it will allow the um
the um
contract it's a very slow process
and where the executive council and um
meet only once a month it will
streamline the process of trying to get
the memorial going
so with that i'll end my testimony and
and try and answer any questions
thank you senator are there any
questions from members of the committee
uh representative thompson
um
senator uh how does the governor and the
council fall on this
if you know
um honestly i haven't talked to them
about it but um i
i can i was just on the phone with them
a little bit ago i can um follow through
i haven't heard any
when it passed through the senate i did
not hear any concerns from the
governor's office or the executive
council
thank you
i had uh
um
i had two very close friends
group of phillips and triple lloyd were
killed in the line of duty
and
i think this memorial is very
appropriate
i
i appreciate your comments
representative
any other questions of senator
burnsville
on senate bill 32.
see none thank you
thank you
talk to you soon
[Music]
there is a hand raise
from a blind stronger
welcome
can you hear me
yes we got you now
sorry my internet is a little delayed uh
thank you uh and good morning
my name is brian strong i'm a lieutenant
with the new hampshire state police
and i'm also a member of the new
hampshire troopers association
i'm here to speak to you on the memorial
i am the
project manager assigned to the memorial
and
um
i am hoping that you support this
a minor change to
senate bill 300
what this will allow us it'll allow us
to streamline the process
to disperse uh some of the funds needed
along the way
currently we have a number of
contractors
we don't just have one general contract
we have a number of them
and they are all doing basically the
work
for uh for a donation
and if they happen to come upon
something that they need a part or or a
piece of material
it will delay the process for us to stop
and go to governors and councils to get
that small
piece of equipment or
material that they need to finish the
job all the funds are privately raised
through donations and there is no uh
state money that is being used for this
and we ask that you support this and
help us streamline the process to get
this uh built and we're hoping to have
it built and completed by the end of the
summer
and i'm happy to take any questions
are there any questions from members of
the committee for the tennesseans
seeing none thank you
thank you very much
thanks
anyone else who wishes to testify on
senator 32
which second justify again second time
saying none
i will close the hearing on
senate bill 32
and open the executive session on
bill 32.
what is the desire of the committee
representative mcconnell uh mr chairman
i have ought to pass on senate bill 32.
i will second that
uh representative mcconkie has moved out
to pass and seconded by representative
plutier
discussion from members of the committee
raise your hand if you do
scene 9
the clerk will call the roll
thank you mr chair
representative mcconkey aye
clerk votes yes
representative sumero
i vote yes
representative phidolfi
yes
representative newton
representative post
[Music]
representative boards
representative kaczynski
representative kolansky
representative thompson
yes
representative boyd
boyd votes eye
representative clutier yes
representative edgar
hi
representative evil
yes
representative jack
representative abbott yes
representative faulkner
yes
representative newman
yes representative grassy
yes
representative peter said
representative query
representative bunker
yes
this is representative query sorry i was
muted yes
thank you sir
chairman graham yes
mr chair the motion ought to pass passes
19-0
thank you and i will close the uh
executive session on
uh senate bill 32
is there any objection from feminist
committee to consent calendar
seeing none we will go on the consent
calendar
we will
have our next hearing on senate bill
116.
11 15.
sorry about the delay i especially
apologize for the prime sponsor and
simply looking aside
take a break until
we will start
just one second
oh my god
the time being 11 15
i call
the hearing on senate bill 116
and act relative to the project to
complete construction of ex of an exit
on i-93 in derry and londonderry
to order
and i will call
upon the
time sponsor
uh representative burnsville if she's
here
i am here can you hear me
oh
video and everything
yeah i found it
welcome back uh senator burnsville
um and
bill 116.
thank you um mr chair and thank you
committee again for hearing senate bill
116.
um this was brought on um oh for the
record my name is regina bertzell i'm
state senator for district 19 which
encompasses the towns of derry hampstead
and windham
and i'm the prime sponsor of senate bill
and this bill um is relative to the
project of um exit 4a
a
um dairy has been dairy in londonderry
have been putting money towards um the
completion of exit 4a for a while
um and the department of attend
transportation um a few years i think it
was last year extended the timeout two
to three years
before um they could uh finish it and it
was planned
um planned to be done in i think
two years now it's um extended out two
or three or uh three years and the ta
the dot has brought it back um
within i think six months but this is
basically a project that londonderry and
dairy have been looking forward to uh
getting completed quickly and on time
because they have they have a lot of
economic development that is planning
that they had been planning on
um they can't afford the time that um
the dot has um extended it out
and i know that this is unusual the
10-year plan will
will be dealing with it but i also feel
that we need to let d.o.t know how much
it means to londonderry and derry to get
this job done on time as promised and
maybe not necessarily on budget we're
hoping that there is money from the feds
that will come in to help um speed this
along
and with that i'll take any questions
thank you senator um
are there any questions from members of
the committee for
um
simon jordan
i have one senator and it may be
deferred to uh mr cass when when he
testifies but i was just looking at the
current 10-year plan
where it talks about construction
um being done
um
21 22 23 and finished nothing 24.
is this the delay that you're talking
about
no i believe that last summer they came
out with a delay out to 24.
but again
deputy commissioner cass can better
define that but um we wanted it done to
the 10-year plan
plan
and uh they extended it out because of
the cost
because of the delays i think the cost
had gone up 30 million dollars
and so they had to push that out
thank you any other questions to
the senator
see
thank you very much
thank you have a great day
thank
you um
the only other person that i have signed
up to speak
um
is
mr
william cass of new hampshire d.o.t
welcome back to the community mr cass
good morning thank you um
can everybody hear me all right i just
wanna
connection is there good
um yeah thank you for um
letting me uh testify to the bill i just
want to
make sure i clarify things so that
everything is clear i can offer a little
bit more detail from what senator
birdsell had
had presented in terms of uh and i'll do
it very quickly some of the history of
the project
um so i think
um
from what i understand and from the
testimony and discussion with with the
senate that the legislative intent is
clear
some of the language in in the bill if
it is strictly interpreted may be
um
[Music]
a little concerning but
um
so
the the bill is described as the design
build exit for a
project um to complete the design build
project named dairy londonderry
so we had proceeded with this project
under a design build procurement which
um
which was all intended to accelerate the
delivery
of the project
last fall when we opened bids for the
from the design bid consultants
the bids were uh and and
as senator had pointed out more than 30
million dollars over our estimate and
because of that and and after debriefs
with the design build teams and looking
at
the risk and the things involved um
we decided not to award the contract and
to take a step back
and to proceed with the project under a
more conventional
design bid build procurement
[Music]
approach
because of the risk involved and in
particularly what we heard was because
of the
right-of-way acquisitions that the
design build team was
was
asked to deal with and they placed a lot
of risk in that
in that area so
taking a step back and doing a
conventional design bid builds
procurement process we had committed uh
and we had meetings uh
last november uh to brief uh a lot of
the local um
um
politicians and the towns on on our um
accelerated schedule to do a design bid
build procurement so
um
it does compared to the schedule that's
in the 10-year plan the 10-year plan had
construction funds
to build this project between
fiscal year or calendar 2021 and 2024.
with the design bid build procurement we
have we recognize certainly the priority
of the project and the needs and we have
worked to accelerate that as as quickly
as practicable
and the schedule we laid out committed
to getting out to construction in the
spring of 2022 so we have a design
consultant um already on board we're
working through the design and and
and things to have a contract ready to
bid in uh 2022
um
but with the right-of-way uh procurement
um uh uh right-of-way acquisitions that
are needed
we uh
do think that that
delivery schedule is gonna extend
between 2022 to 2026.
so potentially two more two years longer
than the schedule that's in the 10-year
plan however we have noted that there
will be
a opportunity there will be a partial
opening of the exit to public use when
you get to
essentially route 28 if you're familiar
with the
um
layout
and you know we anticipate that probably
sometime in 2025
so we may lose a year from what the
original 10-year plan schedule was
planned for
but um certainly not as uh but but i
think we will be having it open to
public use prior to the full build full
fully full construction completion
so that's some of the schedule and the
details and i believe like when we when
when when we talked about
um talked about it with with the senate
that the legislative intent was you know
holding our feet to the fire making sure
that we understood that it was a
priority to the towns of derry and
londonderry and delivering the project
as as soon as possible and as close to
the original 10-year plan schedule as
possible
so i think
the legislative intent is there
the
the the specific language in the tenure
plan from from the schedules and stuff
that we've laid out
is a little challenging in in that
regard so
um
i guess i would just leave it at that
and uh uh can answer any any questions
but we i just would close by saying and
we have assured that the the towns
and senator birdsell that we recognize
it as a priority and we are fully
committed to prosecuting
the design and construction as
expediently as possible
thank you
questions from the committee
thank you go ahead
thank you mr jerich um
my question is the uh
overrun of 30 million dollars
and then taking it back to someone
internally and reworking that do you do
you anticipate
and being out one more year for the
release of that bid
that you'll still be in that range or
do you
is the department hoping that that
number that 30 million will be a lesser
number
we are um
i wouldn't even say hoping i would you
know i just challenged to stay confident
but we are we are pretty certain that
through a conventional design bid build
we can design out
some of the risk that was reflected in
that design bid build price so they were
giving us a a construction price bidding
it on
level plans and there was you know
uncertainty in that that i think was
reflected in the price so
i am relatively confident maybe that's
the best way to put it that we can
design
out
some of that cost increase
whether it will be
you know
fully what our estimate is or somewhere
in between there i do not believe it
will be
30 million dollars more than our present
estimate it may be a little bit more
there is going to be inflation there are
going to be details that we work out
but i think um
we
you know and that was part of our
decision to design to go with the design
bid build that we could not justify at
that time
that cost increase and i believe that we
will deliver it for um
for less
thank you assistant commissioner thank
you
included okay thank you mr chairman uh
mr cass i just want to be clear does the
department may i ask have a position on
this bill
uh
not not not particularly no uh other
than i just other than i just wanted to
point out what what we see is is
kind of some some conflict conflicts
with the with the
specific language
um from from what i understand the
intent
to be
follow
okay if this bill passes as written
what's gonna happen what is wrong i mean
and we need 30 million more dollars
if the bill passes exactly as written i
just want to point out that
the time frame of the 10-year plan at
this at this point
cannot be met
um i think like i said we will get it
started as soon as possible
we will get it started and it will be
under construction
we will have a contract out next spring
but we are not going to be able to
complete it in the um by the 2024 time
frame that's in the present 10-year plan
so
okay thank you mr kev thank you mr
chairman representative thompson
um
deputy commissioner what was the uh
what was the original estimate from your
department for this
round uh round numbers it might have
been 59 something but um
from from uh and i'm talking
construction cost as well now so not
including the right-of-way in the
engineering that needs to be done but
from a construction cost
our estimate was um
right around 60 million dollars and
that's what's reflected in the in the in
the 10-year plan
and who was the contractor that came
back i'm sorry follow-up
who was the contractor that came back
with the 30 million over
well there were three proposals um since
we didn't award the contract um
we can't really talk about the the the
details of the rfp procurement because
we didn't proceed with with the with the
contract so
but the um you know apparent low bid of
of that was more than 30 million dollars
over our our estimate
thank you sir
representative evil
thank you thank you very much deputy
commissioner for coming today um
so i understand uh that it's recognized
that it's unusual to introduce a bill
like this out of cycle with the 10-year
plan
i
understand your testimony that you're
saying that if this is passed as is you
can't achieve it in the time frame
so
what
if we amended it so it was a realistic
time frame what would i mean is there
any reason you can see why we wouldn't
handle this during the regular 10-year
plan
process
in the next term
no
follow-up
um i was just wondering is there
a downside or an upside i mean i
to doing it one way or the other that
you can identify
uh this that for me yeah um
no i mean i i recognize i i certainly
recognize
um
the communities um
not even desire but the but but but the
guy to send a strong message
um i can i i can tell you and i can tell
you know senator birdsall and i did
during the senate transportation that
that message has has been received and
we are committed to
to um you know delivering this project
as as quickly as we can and i believe
that the schedule that we have laid out
um has been recognized and generally
accepted and that you know the the folks
want to see us make sure
make sure that that that we you know
hold to that schedule and do everything
we can to to meet that schedule i
believe that's what the legislative
intent
is here so if if if this bill
you know is is
is
um changed along along those lines that
i mean that that that's that's fine it's
that's your prerogative to to send that
policy
um direction to the department um and
and uh we will do our best to
to meet it so um
but i guess my point is
uh with or without this this this piece
of legislation the the the we we're
fully aware of of that message and fully
committed to
um
delivering this project as expedite as
expeditiously as possible
thank you
thank you representative
yes thank you
deputy commissioner
what what i'm
[Music]
what i'm hearing
is that this
bill
would be
impossible
to achieve
based on the cost
and
the
bidding process going forward and
maybe it would be a good idea
is representative eibel has said
to include this because
what you're saying from a time frame
is that uh
it's not going to be even
[Music]
till next spring
so to and that's one of the major tasks
that we have
for
uh
the next
session
is to uh or the session beginning in
january
is to come up with a 10-year plan
so it wouldn't make more sense to just
include it with that rather than to pass
a piece of legislation that's
unachievable
i
i i
yes yes i would say so the the one thing
i think about this legislation is is to
send that strong message about the the
prioritization of of of the project and
and to that degree
like i said i think the legislative
intent behind it from the discussions
and stuff um is is is is good and we're
honoring honoring that i just had wanted
to point out that that the
you know
a technical direct interpretation of of
the way the bill is written is
problematic at this point uh in the
project
thank you mr chairman uh and thank you
deputy cass for taking this question i
have
the way the
foes bill is written again it talks
about design build
um
i take it from what you were saying is
that you're you're switching over to
the design in it and then constructing
it
it is the way the bill is written right
now would change the way you're
intending to do it and wouldn't that
would that cost more
um
i think it's i think it depends on how
it's interpreted um
the way it is referenced as the design
build project named
uh dairy londonderry it doesn't
necessarily specific uh
[Music]
specifically um
required the design build
procurement but um it could be
interpreted that way based on the the
the description in other words
is is
i mean colloquially it's i think that is
how it was referred to because it was
being developed as a design build
procurement so i think that's where the
reference of the design build project
named dairy londonderry but it doesn't
uh and i think that's what i was trying
to point out some of the maybe
inconsistencies in the bill language
that that um in a strict reading of the
of the
exact language
could be inconsistent
thank you
thank you mr chairman
um
my question would be about what
might happen to the 10-year plan if we
get a
big increase in federal funding um
is it just accelerate everything up or
are we going to be picking projects out
to move up the schedule based upon their
they're being ready to go and is that
going to affect this project
i don't think it will affect this
project
i know even at the governor and council
we've had some discussions um that came
up from council of gatsas relative to
um
you know potential earmark funding and
thing things like that and and
um while additional funding would
certainly be welcome
it is it is not as important in
uh delivering this project at this point
as completing the design in the
right-of-way
um
process so it's not a funding constraint
that is dictating the schedule that is
part of the critical path here
um so i guess that's the answer to the
question and with regard to the 10-year
plan um
there is
[Music]
i hope we know more when we start those
discussions you know this this summer
about
where things are in washington and
additional funding and stuff like that
because there's
been a lot of discussion but uh not a
lot of details to date
good thank you
uh
there's mr david
uh caring the town administrator gary
with the brings him up
hi can you hear me
yeah i'm scared
yeah i'm sorry my uh my feed is cut off
and rejoined uh
thank
the opportunity just to add some
additional comments uh that senator
blaisdell presented and bill cass as
well
just for your information this project
has been a transportation priority for
towns
of dairy and londonderry for decades
it was in the federal record of decision
there were two goals for this project
one is to
promote economic development for both
communities and also to relieve
congestion on route 102 which is uh east
and west broadway here in derry which is
our main through fair
and
again not to repeat what uh what bill
was speaking about but you know unlike
any other project in new hampshire that
has a regional transportation challenge
uh the towns of derry and londonderry
have each committed five million dollars
in local dollars to this project
we've gone from the conceptual stage
from over three decades ago to nearing
construction
and
our our concerns are a couple of uh one
is that we think it'd be critically
important to have the legislative intent
that this project moved forward to
completion as soon as possible
the towns recognize
and agree with bill's position that
final construction will not be completed
until 2026.
that's just the position we find
ourselves in after
the design bill process was completed
with the unfortunate cost overrun
so
our recommendation is that the committee
amend the completion date to 2026
that would send a message to the next
year's 10-year highway transportation
process that this project remains a
priority of the legislature and the
communities
and
my last comment is is that
bill correct me from wrong but i think
actually the construction
project is now viewed as being in three
phases
the first phase will probably be most
visible to
the traveling public with a connection
with i-93
the second and third phases include uh
construction and segments into
local roads and dairy which will be part
of the 4a corridor and our concern is
that without legislative backing
i'm concerned if there are additional
cost overruns
the third phase may be in jeopardy
and if that occurs in a third way third
phase is either not constructed or
delayed
that would simply
transfer a current congested traffic
situation downtown to a separate part of
derry so
again in closing i thank you for your
time and i think it'd be incredibly
beneficial to have a legislature go on
record as having this project as a state
transportation priority and to be
completed by 2026. thank you for your
time
thank you are there any
from members of the community
c9 that is all of
people wishing to testify that i have
nobody else
under
um the attendees will raise their hand
to testify
um
with that i will close the hearing on
senate bill
116. and
just want to say a couple things with
this is within the other bill that we
have in front of us
we have four choices
we can pass the bill as is
we can find the bill in expedient
legislate
we can amend the bill as suggested by mr
karen
or we can retain the bill and make sure
it gets put into the 10-year plan
a year from now correct
if we were to
go with the amended
option
we're not going to get that done today
obviously
um just for the committee's um
information i have scheduled
um the 19th of may for any executive
sessions that we don't get finished
so
that said
before we opened up promotion
um does any of the committee have
something they would like to say about
how they would like to pursue
uh representative newton
yes uh it seems like there's a lot of
questions
with this bill
in
the biggest concern of mine is how it's
going to be paid
and i think that uh referring it to
interim study or retaining it would be
the wise choice to do because
it keeps the pressure on the d.o.t
and we would have plenty of time
to make a decision to add it to the
10-year plan or do some other
alternative action
for the second half of our session so i
would certainly support uh emotion
in that aspect and i think it would be
prudent to move in that direction
thank you representative
thank you mr chair um
i think it would be highly unusual for
our committee to recommend ought to pass
on um
on a bill such as this which is out of
cycle with the 10-year plan
our tradition
at least in my experience has always
been to retain
a bill such as this
i
find it challenging to pass a bill
um especially in its current uh the way
it's currently set up that we're
i i wouldn't want to pass a bill that's
impossible to achieve just to indicate
legislative intent
we have the hearing
record from the senate we have the
hearing record today
the
gasset process will also give these
towns an ample opportunity to represent
their interests
this is
such vital importance it's hard for me
to believe that it wouldn't ultimately
make it into the draft 10-year plan
that's presented to us
and for all those reasons i would have a
hard time supporting anything but
a motion to retain this bill
thank you
any
further discussion before right let's
see what we want to do
if not what is the pleasure of the
committee
representative
i need to retain uh senate bill
116.
second the second proof by
representative clutier seconded by
representative mcconkey that the
committee retained senate bill 116.
i agree wholeheartedly with
representative ebel on the reasons for
retaining bill i think this is a
worthwhile project but i'm concerned i
would not want to pass the bill
definitely the more i have some
questions but i think if we retain it
we have according to the house counter
we have until november 18th you know we
thought there's such report that we
could pass it then and hopefully we're
going to have a clearer picture
of how much federal money hopefully
we're going to get from the
infrastructure which i i think is going
to pass sometime this summer or
certainly early fall and i think it's
going to it may not be what the
president exactly wants but i think it's
going to be for real roads bridges et
cetera that's my fault
i think we need to wait on this but i
think our intent is this is an important
project so i expect in the end i'm going
to vote for tank that has this project
and gets it done as soon as possible but
i think we need to retain it to make
sure there's pressure
on the d.o.t
like representatives to do this
thank you mr chairman
i agree with my fellow committee members
but i'd just like to say
i understand the eggs here with dairy
and londonderry how long projects take
but i wanna i wanna commend the
department here of pulling back and
looking
at an alternative way to get this
project done in a reasonable manner
and it's my hope between that keeping
this retained
that it will work out best for the towns
and
further discussion
i do have one thing for members of the
committee
that
by
late fall when we will have to report
this bill out
we will have a
fairly clear picture
of what will be in the 10-year plan the
gas appearance will be essentially
completed
and we can
if we're not happy with what's in there
that we could fix
this bill and vote on it in january
um it's not going to change what happens
this year um with the agreed plan as the
town administrator said with the agreed
upon uh
timeline that's been laid out now to
take it through 2026.
and i do agree with representatives uh
people including are about um holding
their feet for the fire as well as
representative
and i realized this is not bode well for
our member from dairy but
we're all over sometimes on that
so a further discussion
if not the motion is to retain house
bill 116
clerk will call the roll
representative mcconkey hi
the clerk will vote no
representative sumero
yes
representative cliff
i'm sorry representative newton yes
representative post
yeah representative boards
representative kaczynski
representative polanski
representative thompson
yes
representative boyd
boyd votes high
representative clutier yes
representative edgar aye
representative ebel
yes
representative
jack
representative abbott yes
representative faulkner yes
representative newman
yes
representative grassy
representative peterson
yes
representative query
representative bunker
yes
and the chair
graham folks
yes
1901 the motion passes
thank you and
there's i have no objection to a p
amount of consent count
no it doesn't have to go into it
i close the executive session on
senate bill 116.
um
maybe is in recess until 1 15
when we will hear
senate bill 26.
[Music]
all right
do
i'd like to go to the first
i'd like to go
why am i not
for members of the committee
um it is 114 we'll begin in just a few
seconds with
the final bill of the day
[Music]
but the house always waits till the
right time
and i also want to make sure everybody
comes back
it looks like everybody's here
or as many that are going to be back
um the time being 1 15 by my watch
which is the only one that matters
um
i will call
the hearing on
senate bill 26
and act relative to roads within the
woodsville fire district to order
and i would recognize the prime sponsor
senator guyana
thank you honourable chairman graham and
members
of the committee
about two years ago i was asked by the
haverhill board of selectmen it's one of
the towns in the 27 town district that i
represent
to chair a meeting between the board
and the woodsville fire precinct
commissioners
this meeting was intended to explore
changing the state mandated formula
that dictates
the raising and appropriation of
behavioral tax dollars
and transfer of those dollars to the
woodsville fire precinct for maintenance
of the precincts roads
but the discussion ended when the
commissioners of the precinct
basically pointed to the state law
and refused to discuss any meaningful
change to the formula
it is that law that section one of this
legislation seeks to change
current state law dictates a formula
that requires haverhill taxpayers
to raise and appropriate funds for the
highway department of the woodsville
fire precinct
it requires haverhill to pay the fire
precinct over fifty thousand dollars a
mile
roughly five times the 9 500 per mile
that it costs haverhill to maintain its
own roads
consider that this state law requires
one political subdivision to fund the
highway department of another
that's no different than your town being
told by state government and state law
that it has to fund the highway
department of one of your adjoining
towns
it is an egregious violation of every
tenant of local control
opponents of this legislation will
cleverly ask you to kill it in the
interest of maintaining local control
knowing the respect we in the
legislature hold to this fundamental
prim premise of new hampshire governance
the law we're asking you to amend today
mandates that the taxpayers of one
political subdivision haverhill raises
an appropriate local funds to pay for
the operating expenses of another
political subdivision the woodsville
fire precinct
making matters even worse
the state law requires approval of any
changes to the current financial
arrangement
to gain the approval of the legislature
and the governor
honorable members of the committee this
is not local control
rather this law preempts local control
and eliminates any semblance of good
faith negotiations as demonstrated by
the ongoing refusal of the precinct to
make any substantial changes to the
grossly lopsided state mandated funding
formula
without passage of this legislation
local control does not exist
because state law
governs
this situation
woodsville's hired lobbyist
at a cost to wizville taxpayers of
almost ten thousand dollars so far
asks for time to allow the parties to
resolve their differences
but those differences will never be
resolved so long as this law protects
the state mandated gravy train for
woodsville which disenfranchises the
citizens of behavioral from voting on
the funds that are required by state law
to raise and appropriate every year
for the different political subdivision
i ask you
is this a law that you would support if
your town was the donor town funding
another town's highway department
sadly this issue has fostered deep
division within the community
failure to amend the statute will
perpetuate that division for the
foreseeable future
and the state's continued interference
in this local budget issue will continue
to prevent its resolution at the local
level for as long as it remains in place
section two of the bill was requested by
the department of revenue administration
in response to the woodsville fire
precinct's refusal year after year to
perform the annual audit required of
every political subdivision in the state
despite dozens of emails phone messages
and conversations asking the
commissioners to comply with the law
the department will speak to this
section in subsequent testimony
and finally as an adjunct to this bill
it's instructive to note that the
attorney general recently found the
current administrator of the woodsville
fire precinct guilty of violating
election law
by using fronts from one of the
precincts four enterprises to mail to
every electric and water customer
in its purview a letter advocating
against an article in this year's
haverhill town warrant
that's electioneering plain and simple
the attorney general is also
investigating additional election law
violations for this last march
town meeting as well as reviewing the
financial operations of the woodsville
fire precinct for possible violations of
state law
the multi-year audit mandated in section
2 of this bill has already identified
although not yet complete
several violations of both the municipal
budget act and the municipal finance
statutes
in addition the audit disclosed an
11-year period of potential fraud
against the new hampshire retirement
system committed by paying the
superintendent of the water and light
enterprise 90 an hour full-time wages
but reporting significantly less to the
state so that the employee could
continue to collect his state retirement
income
mr chairman and members of the committee
i respectfully ask for your support for
senate bill 26
to restore local control of haverhill's
budget to the citizens of that community
and to
transparency and accountability and
ensure the integrity going forward of
the business operations of the woodville
fire precinct
thank you for your consideration and i'm
glad to take any questions
uh thank you senator are there any
questions from members of the committee
seeing none thank you
thank you mr chairman and i will have to
go because our senate is now in caucus
are republicans and so
i will not be able to pursue uh to
follow this uh this hearing any further
thank you for your support
thank you
um
i have about 15 people
who have asked to testify
i would ask everybody whether you're in
support or opposition to the bill
to be concise
and if somebody has already said what
you were planning on saying
not repeat that
it is difficult enough for
all of the members
who are on zoom which is all of us with
all of the uh people who are
testifying
to keep track and it
would just make things go a little
smoother so that we can make a a logical
decision
um
second up i would like to call stephen
robbins from winston
if he's here thank you
and if you can everybody could identify
themselves and who they represent if
they represent anyone
my name is steven robbins
lived in woodsville
since i was three years old in 1969
and i
do not support this bill um
i believe that that we have some issues
within our town that um
need to be
dealt with locally not dealt with at
your level and um
i think that this bill
and
um senator guida have worked very hard
to divide our community
and the only way that we're going to
correct this is to bring the parties
together
that this affects
and
let us decide how to fix our own
problems um
the woodsville taxpayer
will be double taxed
by
implementing this this bill um
and i don't think that's fair to to
those of us that that live in the
woodsville district of the town of
haverhill
um again this whole
the initial system was built
and designed so that so
that we were not double taxed and by you
approving this bill and moving it
forward
um we again will be double taxed
so
thank you
thank you mr robins any questions from
members of the committee
saying none thank you
next is
um the town manager of the town of
haverhill bridget codeling hopefully i
said the name right if not please
correct me
nope that is correct can you hear me
yes
hi my name is bridget coddling i am the
town manager for the town of haverhill i
came to work here in haverhill in april
of 2019
so i
um
have
uh been looking over this situation for
the last uh two years
and have been able to do a lot of
research um related to this and have sat
through numerous meetings um related to
this subject so i uh thank you for
listening to us today um i'm going to
read you my testimony and then i'm going
to email it to you
um
i'm writing uh to provide you as
representatives of the people of of new
hampshire information pertaining to
senate bill 26 relative to the roads of
the whistle fire district
senate bill 26 as amended in the senate
grants the woodsville fire district the
option of operating its own highway
department and maintaining its eight
miles of roads at the district's own
expense
the woodsville fire district like other
precincts
is a separate and distinct municipality
from the town
the entire purpose of forming a precinct
or village district is to allow a
smaller group of residents to manage
their own needs by removing some power
from the existing municipality in this
case the town
woodsville has a separate legislative
body
and a separate governing body through
which it exercises his their power
however with that power comes
responsibility
specifically precincts are responsible
for funding their own activities
woodsville has the authority to raise
and appropriate its own funds from its
own residents woodsville is free to
raise appropriate and expend as much or
as little money as its voters and
governing body feel is appropriate the
town has no control over that
the woodsville fire district should not
have its cake and eat it too
the woodsville because woodsville wants
the independent power to operate its own
highway department without
accountability to the town voters yet it
wants the town taxpayers the majority of
whom do not live in woodsville
to fund it
even though the town's highway
department is equipped with a cape and
capable of maintaining the precinct's
eight miles of roads
put it simply to put it simply having
the town fund woodsville's highway
department operations places the burden
of funding the municipal operation of
one municipality woodsville on the
taxpayers of another municipality the
town while simultaneously depriving the
town authority and accountability over
the expenditure of those funds this is
wholly inappropriate and runs afoul of
basic principles of municipal governance
and expenditures
this is even more troublesome given the
fact that the woodville fire district's
highway department only serves the area
within its own precinct boundaries three
square miles and provides no benefit to
the lard the town at large
the town of haverhill should not be
required to fund woodsville's own
internal operations which solely benefit
woodsville
highres state due to its importance that
the town of haverhill is willing and
able to maintain the roads within the
woodsville fire district through the
town's highway department who already
maintain 72 miles of roads
the town's highway department already
maintains these roads throughout
haverhill and is prepared to take on
eight miles of roads within the
woodsville fire district
the town is ready willing and able to
take on road maintenance for all of its
residents including those in woodsville
however so long as woodsville desires to
retain its own independent power to
operate a highway department within its
borders it should bear the
responsibility to fund the same
the town of haverhill asks that you
please
allow the passage of senate bill 26
thank you are there any questions
of um this code name from members of the
committee
please have this radius representative
faulkner
yes thank you mr chairman
manager coddling
right now
the
woodsville district maintains those
eight miles of roads themselves is that
correct
they do they have their own highway
department and they maintain their eight
miles of roads yes right and so and the
money for that
comes from what the taxes that are
raised town wide in the
formula gives them
roughly 25 based upon assessed value is
that is that correct
um that's part of it yes i'm sorry i
should be asking for a follow-up
um
so
if if this occurs
that
if we take away that
responsibility
you would still be raising funds town
wide and then they would be distributed
between the woodsville district and
everybody else according to however the
town meeting
uh approved of the town budget is that
is that what's being proposed here
with senate bill 26 what it does is it
takes away the requirement of the town
to fund the woodsville highway
department
um making woodsville responsible for its
own operations that they choose to have
um for within their their precinct and
they have full authority over that
um and then it leaves it up to the town
the at the uh town level to decide
whether there are services that
woodsville's providing that the town
would pay for
if i have a question i still don't
get any point here
that
the town at the town raises a hundred
thousand dollars for highway maintenance
according to the current
uh situation they pay
a proportional share to woodsville
approximately 25 percent
sometimes it's it's up to almost 30
percent so it fluctuates so so that that
reflects the amount of money that's
actually raised from that district
because it's based upon
a proportion of the uh pro-rata share of
the assessed value
so essentially just giving them back
money that's raised from that district
for highway maintenance
so so when you think about um
the two different layers of government
so you have the town and then you have
the precinct
there are similar activities where
the town is providing
for example police services to
woodsville so the entire town raises
about a million dollars a year to have a
police department and to and to operate
that police department however about 70
between 70 and 80 percent of our police
force forces throughout the year and our
dollars are spent in the woodsville
precinct
of course what do you think about equity
um
certainly um haverhill at large is
paying the the largest portion of that
but the services are being provided in
woodsville so
you have to kind of separate the town
from the precinct the precinct is a
municipal entity it gets to choose
in this case to have a highway
department
and and no one else has control over
that but the individuals in woodsville
however the rest of the town is
responsible for
for assisting with paying for that
and even though we already operate a
highway department
and so that the difference is okay
that um the town's highway department
budget is about 780 000 woodsville's
department highway department budget has
gone up to almost half a million
so that's
that's for eight miles of road
roads where we have 72 miles of roads
that we cover for 780 000. so even
though
it sounds like you're you're you're
going apples to apples with with giving
them back every penny that they raise
it's it's not that equitable
it's the same with welfare as well so
everyone in town pays the welfare budget
um but the same the same um ratio goes
to woodsville most of our welfare
dollars are spent in woodsville but
everybody pays for that because it's a
town
thank you
mr chairman and it's called link
question i have is what percentage of
the town's base tax rate is raised from
the fire district area
isn't that the majority of the
commercial
property in the town of april
yes so there's about 20 percent of the
tax base in in the woodsville precinct
because of the commercial buildings the
commercial enterprises there
and
as i understand it woodsville provides
favorable with ambulance service
yeah we pay about 150 000 a year for
that
all right thank you very much
any further questions
seeing none
um thank you very much
thank you
mark is on the phone
um
wheeler stephen
will be next
inside
we will get to that later
um
see jennifer butcher
hello
welcome to public works and highways
thank you
um
my name is jennifer boucher i am the
assistant town manager for the town of
haverhill
um i just wanted to give you a little
background about myself um
i graduated
laude from casting state college
with a bachelor of science in business
administration and a concentration in
accounting
following graduation i worked for
several companies in various financial
positions
in 2018 i went to work for the town of
piermont as their executive assistant
and i
did anything from them from select board
meeting minutes to welfare
administration to finances
part of my financial duties for them was
preparing and submitting all town
financials to the department of revenue
administration
and while i worked at the town of
piermont i also attended a number of
trainings
to gain more knowledge and understanding
of municipal governments
including courses with the lgc academy
about municipal finance
i came to the town of haverhill in 2016
as their finance officer and
administrative assistants
part of my responsibilities included
include preparation of the annual town
budget
questions regarding the calculation of
the woodsville highway funding started
to arise during the preparation of the
2018 budget process
as finance officer i made the decision
to move employee health insurance
benefits out of the individual
department line items
into one line item
as a result of this this reduced the
total highway budget
by about 10 percent
um and this
budget figure is what's used is in part
of the woodsville highway funding
calculation
because of this change the precinct
commissioners felt the town was no
longer providing them with adequate
funding
the town manager that hired me retired
in november of 2018 and an interim town
manager came in
to prepare the 2019 budget the
woodsville commissioners then went to
him to express their concerns about the
funding of the woodsville highway
department
and i was redirected to calculate the
woodswell highway funding to include the
health insurance benefits
although i disagreed i did recalculate
the funding and included the revised
figure in the 2019 budget
the woodsville commissioners still
continued to question the highway
funding calculation and brought up their
concerns with the new town manager who
was hired in april 2019.
the new town manager requested i provide
her with the information regarding the
woodsville highway funding which i did
um i gave her the spreadsheet that i
used as well as the memorandum of
understanding that was used that the
spreadsheet was created based on
we both her and i reviewed the
documentations and agreed that the
spreadsheet being used in calculating
the highway funding did not accurately
correct capture the memorandum of
understanding so i was then asked to
revise the spreadsheets to more
accurately reflect reflect the
memorandum of understanding
after the spreadsheet was revised we
would hold a meeting with the selectmen
and the woodsville commissioners to
discuss the revisions and work towards
reaching an agreement about the funding
formula
my revisions were meant to provide a
starting point for the selectmen and
commissioners to work together to come
up with a funding formula which more
accurately reflected the memorandum of
understanding
the commissioners were unwilling to work
with this leftboard towards a solution
in an attempt to reinforce the
memorandum of understanding as law
sb-75 was introduced in 2009 and was
passed as amended
however the 2009 change to the law is
unclear as to what the formula actually
is
therefore the town has had to refer back
to the 2008 memorandum of understanding
for its calculations
over the years since the introduction of
the memorandum of understanding
the town has typically provided the
precinct of woodsville funding that
equates to 30 to 50 percent of what the
town budgets for our highway
department for example in 2018 the
town's highway budget was seven hundred
and sixty nine thousand five hundred two
dollars
and the town provided the woodsville
precinct with four hundred and twenty
nine thousand two hundred and three
dollars in funding for their highway
department
that funding equates to 55.77
of what the town spent on their roads
to further put this into perspective the
town spent that 796 000
to maintain 72 miles of road within our
jurisdiction
while the town provided the precinct of
woodsville with 429 thousand dollars to
care for the their eight miles of road
that's ten thousand six hundred and
eighty seven dollars being spent per
mile by the town in comparison to 53 650
per mile being spent by the precinct
in 2020 when the revisions were made to
the formula the precinct of woodsville
received about 115
hundred and eighty two dollars from the
town
which equated to sixteen point six eight
percent of the town's highway budget
that reduced their amount spent per mile
to fourteen thousand four hundred and
ninety seven dollars which is more in
line with what the town spends
maintaining our roads
to me it seems financially irresponsible
for the town to be providing these large
sums of money to maintain through their
three square miles
of roads located within the 52 square
miles of the town
in addition windsville property owners
are property owners of the town of
hayward and therefore just as
responsible to pay for the maintenance
of the town roads as a property owner
jose lives in haverhill corner
the town has its own highway department
that is completely capable of
maintaining the roads within the
boundaries of the precinct of woodsville
however the precinct of wizville made
the choice many years ago to ask the
state for permission to create their own
highway department and they were granted
that permission
therefore it is the responsibility of
the property owners within the precinct
of woods hill to fund their precinct
highway department
and this is what sv 26 is attempting to
do
i ask you to
please vote for sb 26 as amended and
give the town back local control of its
road funding
thank you
i do have one request
if what you just said
you have written
if you've given us a lot of facts
figures
and and
the rest
um
if you could email that to the committee
i would be truly appreciative
absolutely thank you yeah
any other questions
for
this future from members of smith
saying none thank you
um i noticed that one of the other
sponsors of the bill
representative weiler is
in attendance i'm not sure
if he wishes to speak or not
if you do represent weiler raise your
hand or
yes not
um if
all it says is new user under your name
i wish you identify yourself and
read from
26 is
[Music]
matthew
new york rick and i know i screwed that
hello
can you hear me yeah we can hear you now
all right sorry about that that was a
wake up huh
um i appreciate the opportunities my
name is matthew mcdelbrick i'm currently
the vice chair for the haverhill select
board
um i just want to reiterate a couple of
things um that
senator guida had spoken about
we
they talked about local control and we
had i was part of that original
negotiation
back about two years ago and i said we
had approximately three maybe more
meetings that were kindly chaired by
senator gaida and representative rick
ladd
uh themselves they actually came down in
this uh
to attempt to um
help these negotiations uh and they were
completely fruitless we had
we had no
no um nothing came of those negotiations
at all um what i'd like to say is that
this is the antithesis of local control
this arrangement as it stands now is the
only one like it in the entire state of
new hampshire where
the state basically ties the town's
hands and they dictate to us how our
locally raised highway taxes are to be
spent
um
it just like i said woodsville is a
separate and distinct municipality and
under the laws in new hampshire
they have the opportunity to choose what
services they wish to provide for their
own people so
when uh in been part of those
negotiations that we had one of the
commissioners had stated well we just
want our highway money back but problem
with that thinking is when they want
their highway money back
to use on their roads only within their
district they're not paying for the
other 72 miles of road that
all the residents of of the town of
haverhill use
um and like manager codling has stated
you know almost 80 percent of our police
resources are spent within that
municipality there of woodsville but yet
we don't partition out the police bill
like that you know everybody takes equal
share when you join a town
you contribute a little bit and i think
you receive a lot in return and that's
the case here because going forward when
you get 28 30 percent of our
road budget that has to be returned to
woodsville what happens is going forward
for it
for eternity every time the town of
haverhill decides they need a plow they
need a truck they need a greater they
need to attend you know
you have to add 30 percent to that
purchase price
to hand over to a municipality it's it's
it's really not a fair or equitable
solution it's uh it's heavily weighted
it's a lose-lose situation for the town
and and
we don't begrudge the woodsville
precinct anything they
they have their well within their legal
rights to have their own
um
highway department and
you know maintain their roads as they
see fit but they have the they have the
obligation to pay for it themselves that
they can only provide the services that
their taxpayers are willing to
to pay for and that's that's how i see
it should work
um
it's it's just
it's just about fairness and and like i
said that's what happens because it's
it's a bad precedent to set going
forward so
you know on a statewide level what would
happen if the larger municipality said
to the state well we have our own police
department we don't want to contribute
to the state police it would slowly
erode and this is this is just a law
that really
needs to be changed and i would please
uh
please please ask you to
vote for sp 26 as it is amended thank
you for your time
um
representative boyd
mr chairman thank you and uh vice
chairman jailbrook thank you very much
for your testimony question i understand
from doing my due diligence that last
year the town of haverhill
at their annual meeting decided to
create their own fire department and
that they would be inviting
the north haverhill and haverhill corner
fired precincts
into that um
new department that was created is is
that
still the plan of attack for the town of
haverhill
oh yes sir our um
i'll give you a once over the world on
that um the uh
it that plan initiated when um
the haverhill corner people came to us
with the idea of
maybe becoming part of the town and
forming a single department so we put a
vote to the town's people at town
meeting it was approved
we had to obviously get the town to sign
off on it first
and and the bill as pat the
warren article has passed stated that
there was three
fire departments within the town of
haverhill that was haverhill corner
north haverhill and woodsville so the
town agreed to if the precincts
uh
approved to give up their
fire responsibilities
they would join the town fire department
and then the town
would pay for the entire department and
north haverhill and haverhill corner
both joined the fire department which is
now the haverhill the town of haverhill
fire department uh unfortunately
woodsville um the commissioners the
first year didn't put it they didn't
allow it to be voted on and i believe
this year
they turned it down
so
they chose not to become part of the
town fire department unfortunately
follow up mr chairman
thank you mr chairman um
fight chairman for jailbreak
just so that i understand as i i
appreciate the testimony
that uh town manager coddling provided
i'm just trying to understand
the relationship
of the woodsville highway department as
it relates to the woodsville fire
district
are they are they a department under the
woodsville fire district or are they
department under the guise of the town
of haverhill
no they they fall into the woodsville
fire district
okay so it's their own highway
department under the fire district
that's correct sir
okay wonderful thank you very much for
your testimony thank you mr chairman
thank you for your time sir
representative
thank you mr chairman um thank you sir
for being here
um you folks are so involved in this and
it's you know and i think we're all
trying to get up to speed to understand
uh the situation
um
i can't find the statute that this is
amending on online so i see everything
in its totality someone testified they
said this is the maybe it was you uh
that this is the only situation in the
entire state of new hampshire like this
so
if
if you just take us back in time i'm
trying to understand why this
is in state law in the first place uh
was it because there was so much
division um somebody just tried to
settle it through legislation
or how did this come to pass
uh this the original uh law it predates
me obviously um by believe the um over
the over time there's been numerous
amendments and they've come back to the
state to amend it
um
i i don't know i couldn't uh
intelligently speak to when the first
law was enacted regarding this but i
believe the recent the most recent
amendment to it i think was 2009
if i'm if i'm uh correct
well i i just as a follow-up just as a
matter of history i was trying to
understand how how this came to pass in
the first place um
so
my other question is one of the people
testified that if
this law was passed people in woodsville
would be double taxed and i wondered if
you could speak to that
um sure well i i can't speak to what um
i think it was mr robbins that stated i
can't speak to what he what he meant
but um
double taxed um well no because
when you pay into the high will highway
uh tax the highway taxes in the town
you're contributing to
all of
the town roads not just
you know a specific precinct
so
like i said we all contribute um
i guess i could say it like this for
example we i i pay taxes to the state
and and
by extension the um
the county for
and that pays for the state police it
pays for the
county sheriff's department yet
haverhill we have our own town police
department
i mean would you consider that double
taxation i wouldn't because
the town chooses
to have our own police department so for
that we have to raise the taxes through
the town and pay for that it doesn't it
doesn't relinquish us of our
responsibilities to contribute to the
state police or the county
sheriff's department we can't say oh we
have our own we don't want to contribute
i i don't see that as double taxation
it just
if you want to improve your services to
your specific community as we do with
the town for example with the police
department it's just a burden that we
have to shoulder if we want that so i i
really wouldn't see that ma'am as double
taxation
just one more follow-up mr chair
um okay
so
there's been a couple of statements
regarding local control what is and
isn't local control is it your testimony
then that the laws that currently exist
does not allow for local control and if
this bill was passed it would return
local control to
um
the people of haverhill and woodsville
yes ma'am absolutely just as i had
stated before if it would allow it would
it would unshackle the town
and we wouldn't have to be
paying for
a department of another municipality
so
if woodsville wants to have a fire a
road
a highway department for themselves then
they pay for it and then they the
taxpayer in woodsville decides how big
they need
or how you know how much they want to
spend to take care of their eight miles
of road and then that would allow the
town to take care of its roads with the
funds that it raises
thank you
uh mr chair
yes
uh i just wanted to uh make a point um
mr darren clogston is on your scheduled
list of people to testify um when you're
ready to call him he have he has
connectivity issues he would be you he's
here right now he could use my uh laptop
to speak to you and address you
there'll be a couple people down
of course just wanted to let you know
thank you sir
um
richard god
next time
he's already in here
you have to unmute yourself mr guy
this guy you need to be on youtube thank
you my apologies i'm uh a little bit new
with this i'll do that
thank you very much i wanted to
introduce myself um i'm in my eighth
year as haverhill cooperative school
board chairman
um i've spent 35 plus years in the town
of haverhill on various boards and
commissions including being
the woodsville board of commissioners
chairman in 2008 and 9 when the current
legislation was passed
this current legislation was the work of
unanimous work of the haverhill select
board and the woodsville commission
the select board under rick glad we all
know and
town manager glenn english and it solved
some real problems
that bill in 2009
uh did receive unanimous support but the
ones that before you today is not
receiving unanimous support locally in
fact i believe you'll find that two of
the five favorable select board members
are registered as opposed to it on your
list today and all of the woodsville
precinct commissioners are opposed to it
as well
unfortunately the bill before you today
recreates the very problem that the
current law was
was solving
it has woodsville property i'm sorry
woodsville taxpayers paying for its own
highway department plus a large share of
the cost of the haverhill department
department and it is considered or it
was considered double taxation back in
the current loss solved the problem
and it works like this the people served
by the woodsville highway department pay
for the woodsville highway department
the people in haverhill
that are served by the haverhill highway
department pay for the haverhill highway
department that is how it works
all of the in all of the discussion
today about how haverhill people are
paying for woodsville or subsidizing
it's just plain on true and it's it's i
think because
the people that are speaking to you
don't fully understand how it works i
think rick ladd has a very good handle
on it and i'm sure he's spoken to you
about it in the past
one nice lady just a moment ago asked
about
the woodsville highway
having its own department and i'll just
throw in that um we've had two highway
departments and it's been mutually
beneficial and served the town and
village well for a very very long time
perhaps up to about 100 years
the bill we're talking about today is
only about funding
why are we here
and
i'm sorry but let me be a little blunt
about this prior to 2019 haverhill was a
very peaceful and cooperative town the
highway departments worked together when
they needed a little extra help
we didn't keep a ledger of the time we
just did it
since the hiring of our new town manager
woodsville has been under siege from
town management you will find that the
town manager is articulate and charming
as you've just heard but she has worked
hard to disrupt all the relationships
using bullying tactics that include
threats of defunding to enlisting
you folks in concord to be uh her heavy
hand
she has defunded the woodsville fire
department
over a control issue she has threatened
haverhill corner fire
and they have pardoned me
to threaten haverhill corner fire
department over um defunding and they
finally gave in
she's attempted to defund or reduce the
funding or replace woodsville ambulance
of which i was a member um and still am
for over 40 years now
and the public did speak up very
harshly about that and they backed away
from it she's refused to pay the town's
obligations to the woodsville sewer
department and she has enlisted the
senate and now the house to fight
letting woodsville keep its local share
of highway funds the people of hayward
are not sending money to woodsville if
they took the time to understand how it
works they would know that
the funding of our highway departments
is simple if you make an effort to
understand it
when this started the town manager and
select board didn't understand how it
works and they believed haverhill was
subsidizing woodsville and with the town
manager in charge as we recently found
out she has blockaded any
efforts recent efforts to get together
and discuss this as a group sorry i'm
stammering a little bit i'm not a great
speaker
at every turn over the last two years
the town manager has been building a
wall between haverhill and woodsville
as the haverhill school board chair i
fear where this is going there is now a
strong sentiment in woodsville to
disengage from haverhill
this bill as written could be that final
brick in the wall
sorry for the pink floyd reference
if woods phil splits from the school
district
we will have a real problem keeping
our table cooperative school system
going
this bill is no more
than a tool that the town manager has
found to further her agenda i ask that
you reject this or return these
discussions to the local level
we're given a we're given a recent
petition for her
dismissal
and voters taking back control of the
select board i believe we have a chance
of resolving this locally if you will
return this issue to us today thank you
for your time
senator boyd
thank you mr chairman and mr guy thank
you for your testimony one quick
question if if it if the voters do
choose in the village of woods of
woodsville
decide to merge their fire department
with the town of haverhill
in in your opinion with your
institutional knowledge
does it solve the problem
i i'm not exactly sure what problem
merging the fire departments is trying
to solve
we have been training our fire
department in woodsville has been
training with the other two departments
for years
they've done group purchasing for years
we only have a fire chief with a ten
thousand dollar salary
i'm not really sure exactly what problem
they're trying to solve by doing this so
um honestly i don't think i'm the right
person to ask that question and be able
to give
okay i apologize if i put you on the
spot mr guy
it's okay it's fine
thank you mr chairman
hey further questions
if not
um
mr english
let's see if i can find them
there he
goes welcome to public works and
highways mr english
mr english if you're there please um
and they were calling you i i have mr
english here if you'd like to okay
you're showing up on something else but
okay
welcome
can you hear me mr chairman yes we can
i want to thank you for the opportunity
to testify
in opposition to sb 26
has currently worded
uh my name is glenn english and i was
the haverhill town manager
from 1995 to 2015.
i also went back for a brief period of
time
when my successor resigned
and worked an additional eight months
to help the selectmen
get to a process of hiring a new town
manager
i was a town resident and taxpayer
during my tenure
and continue to happily reside in the
town
i pay taxes to both the town and the
woodsville fire district where i am
involved in a family business
during my tenure as haverhill town
manager
i and the board of selectmen worked hard
to establish and maintain
a positive working relationship with the
several village districts
which provide some
defined municipal services to their
constituents within the greater town
i think the definition of municipality
has been
misinterpreted by some of the people
testifying
to me a municipality
that is totally separate from another
municipality is not the same thing
as a fire district or a village district
municipal unit within a town there are
shared resources and shared benefits
all the people in haverhill use the
woods use the roads in woodsville as
well as tourists it's our business
center
all of the many of the people in
woodsville use the roads in haverhill so
it's not like there are two distinct
municipalities with a brick wall between
them that's a that's a fallacy
many of the other districts provide
services that benefit the whole town as
well
i won't go into that detail but we have
about four different village districts
water and light departments are done
locally in the district level um and one
of our districts mountain lakes has a
aggressive recreation department that
benefits the whole town in instances
we have
our traditions honor
government services at the very local
level
that is why we have so much diversity of
our local government
and the town administration
the current town administration doesn't
understand that
this has worked well over the years as
long as the lines of communication have
remained open and cooperative
unfortunately that is not now the case
in haverhill
as i see it this proposed legislation
will end fair taxation and local control
for the woodsville taxpayers it will
also mandate overly extensive audit
requirements on the district
well beyond any audit requirements of
any other municipality
sb 26 will end the long established
practice
of returning a percentage of highway
funds raised by property taxation in the
town
based on the town's assessed values to
the haverhill taxpayers who live in
woodsville
the woodsville taxpayers are also
behavioral tax taxpayers you need to
understand that very important
this would result in haverhill taxpayers
in woodsville paying for two highway
departments
paying for two highway departments
double taxation
the second issue local control requires
a brief look at history
the woodsville highway department
predates the town's highway department
it was established in the late 1800s to
build and maintain woodsville's city
streets
these streets are paved and in some
cases have curbing and sidewalks and
closed drainage systems
they are expensive to maintain in
relation to the town's roads which are
rural mostly dirt with open ditches for
drainage the taxpayers in woodsville are
happy and have been happy with their
local highway department
in fact the woodsville fire district
boundaries were enlarged by the
selectmen in the early 1990s because the
town was doing such a poor job
maintaining swift water road which
provides access to cottage hospital
since the town government began to make
incorrect allocation of the highway
funds to be returned to the district
under the present town manager
a violation of the current statute by
the way
the district commissioners were forced
to sue the town to protect
their taxpayers
a mediated settlement or court action
could ultimately decide the issue
if resolution is achieved
any required enabling legislative action
can be brought to the legislature by
both the town
and the district as has been done
successfully in the past
i strongly urge you to vote sp 26 in
expedient the legislate please honor our
traditions of local control
and fair taxation and i would end with
reminding
you and
having you understand
that the taxpayers
in woodsville are also behavioral
taxpayers
thank you
don't tell them are there any questions
seeing none thank you
[Music]
you could have uh darwin kluxton i think
he's sitting with
good afternoon
[Music]
my name is darwin clarkson i don't own a
computer so
um
matthew's letting me use uh use use his
sir
um as i said my name is darwin clarkson
i'm speaking for myself i am in favor of
sb 26
my wife and i have been residents of
pike for over 30 years
the last two years i have served as
chair of the haverhill select board
pike is one of the five villages of
haverhill pike north haverhill the
historic town center of haverhill corner
woodsville and the district of mountain
lakes
we are one community but unfortunately
we are not all treated fairly or equally
by the new hampshire legislature when it
comes to our taxes
taxation or how we spend it
for a little history in 1990 there was a
request for revision to the legislation
for the distribution of highway funds to
the woodsville fire district
it is important to note that five of the
six individuals making this request were
residents of woodsville
much the same happened in 2009 with
another new legislatively mandated
formula for the subsidization of
woodsville
on both occasions there was no town vote
only a decision by elected inhabitants
of woodsville
four of the five members of the select
board in 2009 were residents of
woodsville
meaning most involved personally
profited or benefited more than other
citizens in haverhill
as legislators i am sure you understand
the ethics of such a situation
almost two years ago the select board
voted unanimously to pursue the
statutory changes necessary to make our
road maintenance fair and equitable
discussions with the woodsville fire
district were quickly negated by
woodsville commissioners smiling and
stating the formula is a law
and the law is the law we cannot change
it on the town level
negotiations were not and are not
possible with such comments as and i
quote
no review of the process is needed nor
will it be tolerated
the state statute stands in the way
since the first hearing held in the
senate which passed the repeal 24-0 in
2019 haverhill select board members have
been threatened and made to feel unsafe
town manager bridget cardling has been
called useless in psychotic in bimbo
previous town manager glenn english who
you just heard from said he would and i
quote crucify
her if she attempted to change the
woodsville highway funding formula
carling has been the recipient of
exploding pornographic messages and
warned by citizens concerned for her
safety that she should not travel
unarmed
there has been much said in written
about the town of haverhill sville fire
district and local control
there are people who have and will
testify the state law mandating
haverhill taxpayers give woodsville more
than 53 000 a mile for its eight miles
of road is a local issue that needs to
be settled locally
we can
not
only you can repeal the law requiring
haverhill taxpayers to give their tax
money by a legislative mandate to
woodsville
the issue of roads and distribution of
money has been a divisive issue for many
years
woodsville which has eight miles of road
to maintain is legislatively granted
fifty one thousand dollars per mile
the rest of payroll services 72 miles of
road with ninety seven hundred dollars
per mile left from the taxes raised
the taxpayers can only afford so much
and currently the new hampshire
legislature is the only place the
haverhill taxpayers can get released
they are mandated to give woodsville
their tax dollars
until the issue became overwhelming and
a new town manager was hired no one
really knew what was happening
a quick look at the books showed poor
stewardship in a situation where
woosville was overpaid the mandated
amount
just the years 2016 17 18 and 19
represent an overpayment by the
taxpayers of haverhill to the precinct
of woodsville of almost 800 000
our solution which is before you today
is every road mile equals status
regardless of where it begins where it
goes or how many deer or bear cross over
them
it will end the legislative mandates
upon the haverhill taxpayer and allow
everyone to be treated as equals
every precinct has the ability to create
whatever services it wants so long as
the want is paid for by a precinct tax
and is in accordance with state law
a water company electric company
ambulance service or fire department if
they want it they can have it and pay
for it
i am of the opinion that the existing
law has allowed those responsible for
the serious financial obligations that
have been precipitated investigations by
the dra and the attorney general to act
with impunity
they believe they can manipulate the
legislature through a couple of elected
representatives
this is given the taxpayers a belief
that if you have money you can even take
more from the little guy the working
family by having friends in concord
it's time for equal treatment of all
people of the town of haverhill
please remove the mandate the
legislature created which interferes in
haverhill's right to govern itself
please allow haverhill taxpayers the
ability to control their own destiny
please restore the faith people need to
have in its government and most of all
those elected to govern
it is interesting to note that the
attorney general has just found the
woodsville fire district guilty on two
counts of electioneering
it is my understanding there are six
more counts pending
ironically this returns one of the
woodsville residents michael graham
who benefited and signed road
legislation to the haverhill select
board after a 20-year hiatus
from using government mail paid for by
taxpayers to having the police remove
legal signs from private property this
legislation and its profits to those in
woodsville pushes the limits of criminal
activity
the use of government mail
has been brushed off by the state
election officials because the lifetime
ceo
if we could
focus on
the bill and not allegations of other
wrongdoing or other problems
within the town of april as a whole
i would appreciate it
my apology sir
i ask you sincerely to repeal the law
mandating haverhill taxpayers subsidize
the private enterprises of woodsville
commissioners
and allow all of haverhill taxpayers to
act as one family
thank you
any any questions for members of the
committee see none
thank you for your testimony thank you
for your time sir and we will hear from
the honorable robert clay
welcome back to the general court
thank you sir i i miss it sort of
not the zoom though
thank you mr chairman members of the
committee for the record i was a member
of the legislature both the house and
the senate i spent 14 years and i truly
do understand
what you give up to be a volunteer
citizen legislator and i will say right
now i would never support any other type
of legislation legislature
because i think this is the way things
get done
as to to senate bill 26 the reason why
i'm even involved is a few years ago i
just just for the record i like to
restore historical structures
so i was approached because a few
historical structures were going to
be either demolished or turned into
apartments
and i agreed to buy them and fix them
right now i have four
two of them are under renovations and
and two others are not yet
but i i also
somehow got involved politically
and part of it was because the tax base
um haverhill i think is the fifth
highest taxed
community in the state of new hampshire
so i started looking at my appraisals in
the appraisals of other important people
and said okay something's not right
so as we started looking up came
the uh road money
i remember they were buying a grader for
a hundred thousand dollars and had to
raise a hundred and thirty so that they
could give woodsville thirty thousand
dollars directly
so we started looking at exactly what
was happening but what we have
is is a as a long-standing dispute and
to to representative ebola
this started in the late 1800s and
there's actually a court case a supreme
court case in the state of new hampshire
from
and it just happened to discuss
if if woodsville took care of its own
roads who were responsible
for any accidents or who have the
liability
and the court back then said haverhill
holds the liability regardless of who
actually does it because
haverhill is the town that actually owns
woodsville in a sense
so and it's just gone on over and over
again now the reason why there was a
dispute is because in the late 1800s the
railroad was making a decision
originally haverhill corner was the
center of the universe up there and
that's where all the circuit courts met
i think three months a year
um every house in haverhill corner
including the ones i own were either a
tavern
a bed and breakfast or both during all
those years because there was no place
else for people to stay
so what happened was that the railroad
suddenly became the boss
and if you look at all of the the
history for the state of new hampshire
you will find
the railroad became too powerful
controlled the legislature to the point
where there was an actual
serious fight to get the railroad out
so you ended up having money
allocated
based on
powerful influences
but it brings us to 2009 in 2009
as
mr clarkson said
there were
four people who were selectmen
that were
members of woodsville and one who who
belonged in haverhill corner
who happened to be a state rep now when
you hear the testimony earlier that said
that
the commissioners in woodsville approved
this deal
and the selectmen approved the deal well
when you have
we have eight people
and seven of them are going to benefit
financially
it's pretty hard not to have eight
people who are going to agree
now you also hear that
people have said the law is the law and
that's exactly what's happened
in 2009
um the representative and the state
senator
uh put this before and i found out from
the representative
on april 26
that they had a hard time actually
getting the bill from 2009 through
the legislature didn't like it
so they pulled a trick
where you take it and you put it in
house bill 2. i'm sure most of you uh
understand that that
process
and that's how it came about
because it it was
then
looked at as hey wait a minute i'm not
sure this is fair
so anyways it became law
and then
the more they looked at it they looked
and said as you heard from jennifer
in 2018 or 19
they found that they were making
overpayments
and a previous
manager
actually had admitted that yes he knew
he was overpaying woodsville but he felt
that they deserved it but he also lives
in woodsville
um and and so you know we go on and on
and on
it's been very difficult to sit with
them
and yes i've been with senator geider
and and and rick glad in the beginning
and we looked at it and said how do we
fix it
well i i don't blame woodsville
they smile and say
there's nothing to fix
we get almost half a million dollars a
year because the legislature says we do
so what is there to talk about there's
no reason to talk to you
and that's why we have to hit
representative rick ladd said in 2019
when the bill that this was in was a big
omnibus bill and it was vetoed by the
governor because there was too much in
it
he said it's it's it's none of concord's
business concord needs to get its nose
out of haverhill's business
and i agree with what he said but i
don't think he agrees with why
i agree that conker should take its nose
out of haverhill's business
why does concord think it's okay for
them to say
haverhill gets this much money
and out of that money
they have to give this much to one
precinct
now the precinct
doesn't need the money they said well
they do because they want all the tax
money but when you look at it all of
haverhill including them
use all the roads
so
haverhill says we use woodsville roads
you use havel roads we all use
everybody's roads together
so why are we paying together
and what woodsville's return return is
it doesn't matter what you use we take
care of our roads
and we'll take all of our money well you
know it's 420 000
a year
that we can't afford i'm a taxpayer so
i'm speaking as a taxpayer now
we can't keep doing this
now
there's a second part of this bill that
i'm surprised nobody's talked about
and it's the audits and the audits are
tied closely
to to the road money which is why they
dra asked to put their
piece in
the audits show the misuse of road money
some of you have been on the committee
long enough to know that federal and
state money comes with caveats there are
certain things you can and can't do with
it
but how many of you know
that in 2009
they have they had um
i'm trying to see where it was
the the the the statement was made
this will provide
woodville precinct
with an another hundred thousand dollars
which will help in maintaining
the sewer system water
sidewalks
problem is is all of those are privately
owned enterprise systems
not entitled
to taxpayer money and not entitled
to road money road money is supposed to
be used for roads it's not supposed to
be used to repair the water system
especially when it's a for-profit
business
so when they started asking
for audits out of woodsville
the town manager of haverhill
said the dra oh don't worry about it's a
bunch of good old boys they just don't
understand but we know everything is
okay
as he left
certain things came up
and dra said we need the help of the
legislature because we need to do this
audit
now
they've done the audit because the ag
has stepped in and dra has stepped in
and and i have um
looked at it
they have some
serious
uh issues one that bothers me the most
having been on the new hampshire
retirement system
on the board when i was in the
legislature
11 years
of having an employee they called
part-time
and i guess he was collecting
but he um
they were calling him part-time and then
paying him something that was called
calm time basically they were paying the
gentleman ninety dollars an hour
in telling the retirement system that he
was just getting a pittance these are
the things that we're finding in the
audit
the electric company is another one
it's supposed to be a municipally owned
enterprise
yet it sells
electricity across state line which
makes it federal
the puc is under the impression in the
state of new hampshire that because it's
municipally owned and it only services
itself
it can't regulate it
and the the answer to the federal is we
don't sell anything across state lines
well they do
and and where's the money
i was part of a team
that was um
hired by someone to go in and look for
the money
i've sat with dick guy
i've asked for the information
um i was told he doesn't have it i was
taken to the superintendent
and the superintendent turned white we
thought he was gonna have a heart attack
and said i don't have the books only
dick guy does so i'm not making any
accusations i'm only telling you what's
in the audits what i've experienced
myself
part two of this bill
is just as important
as part one
part one says to the legislature
kind of get out of our business
eight miles of road is nothing for
haverhill to take over
and i will tell you that
the the fight
in haverhill during the last election
was to make sure that the
greater
and the dump truck that was necessary to
to work the roads
couldn't be
they couldn't keep the lease contract so
they did something that basically
defunded
but to the managers the town manager's
credit
she found another way to make sure that
she kept the equipment to keep the roads
going so what we have is we have
a big fight
you're not going to fix the fight over
the roads unless the
legislature says
it's not our business it's your business
and then i guarantee you
there's a group of people who want to
sit down
and work it out
but woodsville is not going to get 420
000 a year because
the town of haverhill in its different
precincts
if you're making money off the water and
you're making money off of selling
electricity and you're making money off
of selling the sewer use
then then you shouldn't be taking our
money to maintain them
you should be using your money the money
you make off of selling that product
and that's what we're asking we're
asking you
to take concord out of the road money
and i'm asking you to
make sure that dra
can finish its audit work and it's not
just woodsville
that would have to follow this audit
process it's everyone it's time that
taxpayers
had the ability
to see exactly what it is people do with
the money that's raised and appropriated
i can tell you
that one investigator i know has been on
this since 2009 on the electric
they still can't find out
where the money goes
they're they're getting close because
dra is forcing the audit
and and um there's a lot of things
happening a lot of people trying to
cover
but but the reality is
the people in in haverhill as a town all
five precincts
a good hard-working
people
they're working families
and they're trying to keep their head
above water
being number five
in taxes in the state of new hampshire
these are simple people there's not a
lot of luxuries there
and it's not fair
the only fair thing is for the state of
new hampshire's legislature to say
this is your problem we're repealing the
mandate that you give them this money
and you pass the second set
so that the people in woodsville is
whether the people as well as the people
in haverhill
know
what actually happened to all the money
they've been fun fun funneling into that
division
mr chairman i'm going to
send in my original testimony
i wanted to make sure that
i answered some of the questions i hope
i did
i'd be more than happy to answer more
i've been around a long time as some of
you know i've been a selectman i've been
a budget committee member
i was a member of the house for eight
years i was a member of the senate
and that drove me out
but
i i i fully understand
um
i'm done
go on
go ahead and finish
no actually i actually i i'm i'm i'm
done mr chairman um i i want you to know
i'm passionate
i i have a place up there that i'm
probably going to retire
i um
it's it's a beautiful it's a beautiful
community
but what's been happening to it over the
years just isn't right and and it's
because
uh people in haverhill are old-fashioned
um
new hampshirites
and they believe that
everybody is trustworthy and sometimes
that's not the case
representative you got a question
yes thank you and thank you uh mr clegg
for the history lesson it just really
helps put some things in context so
if i um may see a seem like a small
point considering everything else you
testify to but if i understand what you
just said
there really wasn't a lot in this
statute about funding until 2009
and when that and and that was
introduced i understand as part of hb2
and that's because at that point there
was already vast disagreement
going on
let me let me just say that there was
there was a formula in there but it was
nowhere near this and what it said was
that
haverhill had to give woodsville up to a
certain amount of money which meant that
if haver was spending nine thousand
dollars a mile on its own roads
it had to give nine thousand dollars a
mile for the other eight eight miles but
it also said that should some kind of
catastrophe happen in in woodsville that
haverhill would would would continue to
be part of thing it wasn't until 2009
that greed took over
and that's been the problem
see no further question oh
representative thank you very much mr
chairman uh
representative former senator former
senator representative clay i have a
question you talked about this plot that
i maybe i'm missing something
is this audit been completed
um it's a it's five years of audits um
the first two years are are done we're
in 2017.
um
i've looked at them the first two were
pretty bad the 2017 isn't good
but um the rest of the other two years
are not done yet
okay
follow up
okay when are all the honest gonna
i have to be careful with some of the
information i would strongly suggest
that you get with senator geider and
speak to the the gentleman at dra that's
in charge of this
as legislators you can get more
information okay thank you very much
appreciate it thank you
thank you
representative
yes thank you for taking my question
if this bill passes
does it solve the problem
it it solves the problem because it
allows people to sit down
and and
as i said with all due respect if i was
part of woodsville and i was getting 420
i wouldn't sit and negotiate it away
but if it's gone i would sit there and
negotiate how best to care for the roads
thank you
see no further questions
thank you sir
um
mr stephen wheeler
yes can you hear me yes
yes well first comment would be that
the audits are done all the way to 2017
and 18 and 19 are almost done and there
is no money missing there's been no
misappropriation of money the money that
comes in to the precinct
for water and light is completely
different than when it comes into the
precinct for roads in them because water
and light
and the sewer system and the ambulance
systems are all enterprise systems so
that money has nothing to do with
woodsville roads
and i've heard the figure of five
hundred thousand four hundred thousand
four hundred and twenty five thousand we
only get what is a do us for the money i
am a precinct commissioner we get 23.6
of the road money because 23.6 of the
tax dollars are paid by the people of
woodsville
they would like it until we didn't get
any of the money but that is a fallacy
and there's a lot of other things that
fallacies are what they're spoken about
by the gentleman in front of me first of
all the woodsville road started in 1898.
this was due to because of the railroads
as he mentioned and the city of
woodsville which is not a city but it's
a town was built like a city because we
had to have a sewer system and storm
drains because water doesn't run down
the streets too well and that when
they're tired woodsville had to crew 30
years before the town had a road crew
woods built maintenance agreements have
been modified many times over all these
years and the valuation has grown
this is based on property evaluations
assessing a tax assessments
the last update was held in 2008 which
took effect in 2009
that last agreement has worked fine
until 2019
at that time the border select one of
the advisement of the town manager
changed the formula without the precinct
of woodville having any input
when they have a memorandum of
understanding you have to have all
parties involved in the changing of an
agreement
it appears the spikeboard the town
managers do not understand the full
understanding of that formula and what
it was agreed to in 2008 because the
lack of understanding the precinct of
woodsville has not received their
portion of the taxes collected to apply
the road means this year at all we're
supposed to get it every quarter we
haven't got a cent yet
and he talked about the
the select board actually in 2008 there
was only four members on the select
board because one that resigned when
this was done and they didn't not
replace that person until august and
this this
the agreement was signed in april and
two were from haverhill and two were
from woodsville but they're all elected
by the town people of the town of hagel
so it's not a lopsided board as he said
and i know that for a fact because in
august my wife came back on to serve her
11th year on the select board at that
year she had been a selectman all those
years so i know that for a fact
the woodsville precinct commissioners
have tried to arrange a meeting with the
hebrew
cable uh select board
many times and they refuse to meet with
us they said they couldn't meet until
the lawsuit was over well
we have a we have a copy from their
lawyer and our lawyer that said that we
should meet because before we can even
go to court there has to be a mediation
agreement between the two so i don't
know where it is but
and when one of the select board members
asked to tell manager about this letter
in this email she said i've never heard
of it well five minutes before that
selectmen got to her office the next
morning she put on i guess i
misunderstood what they were talking
about
i mean it's just been the same thing all
the time
uh 23.6 percent of the road money comes
back to woodsboro because 23 percent of
the road money is paid by the precinct
of woodsville i don't know why we
shouldn't get the money back that we've
that was to us because our taxpayers
have be double taxation again
and they also get in double tax stations
on the fire department which we give
23.6 percent of the money to the town
fire department and we don't get a sent
back when we have our own fire
department
um and it just keeps going in the police
call they said that 75 percent of the
police calls well i contacted the
dispatch because all about dispatch goes
through grafton county sheriff's
department
and in the in the last ensuing year 31.6
of the police cars were in woodsville
at not 75
31.6
was it was down in woodsville and most
of those were to walmart which we kind
of
so i mean
the people in woodsville
we had our annual meeting uh two weeks
after the towns
after the tell meeting and the voters in
woodsville at the annual meeting for the
precinct of woodsville the sentiment for
woodsville was to secede from the town
of haverhill
over the years woodsonville is often
perceived as a separate town as many
visitors to woodsville believe that
they're in charge lawyers come up to the
courthouse and they think woodsville is
its own town they come to woodsville we
have all the restaurants we have all the
stores we have all the businesses in
woodsville for that stuff and the town's
complaining about tax money well all the
rooms and meals tax which is almost 200
000 a year goes to the town we don't
receive a cent of it back and we have
all the businesses i don't know what the
hell the problem is there i just get i
just get sick of hearing all this stuff
all the time our road crew has to be
trained
because they do storm drains they have
to be trained to go under the road with
their gas mask
and everything when they go under the
road to fix a storm drain or a suitable
a road crew does fix the sewer grains
but and the money that goes to
woodsville precinct
um comes the woodland precinct water
lights its own entity i don't know how
he figured dick guy was going to because
he was a precinct commissioner was going
to give him books
for the water and light department when
we went a separate entity until last
year at town meeting our annual visit
village meeting when they said oh we're
going to join forces we had not been
joined forces until the night since the
1920s when louisville water and white
was established so i don't know where we
would have got that information from
i've been
i've been a commissioner for over six
years now and i can tell you there's not
one cent missing and the audit that just
came out there's not one cent missing
from woodsville yes we were calm with
layman we didn't have a manager at the
time we may not have done everything
right but there's no money that went
from water and light from the precinct
to water and light because the two did
not get along
and the problem was the guy taking the
money that was retired had nothing to do
with the woodsville road crew because we
had no control over the woodsville water
and light department they were their own
separate entity
i just i just get sick of hearing well
what's bill's just what feels that
there's no money missing we just and
senator geider was up there when they
did the uh review of 2015
16 and 17 i don't know how come he said
the 17 wasn't done 18 is will be done
monday or tuesday of next week and 19
will be done by the middle of may and
there's no money missing not one
cent i think that's about all i got to
say if you want to ask questions
anybody have any questions
see none thank you
we're going to try this one more time
under attendees there is some
it says new user
um
iphone number there is no phone number
there's nothing um
so we have brought you in
if we could
that was who you are and what your
position on the bill is we would
appreciate it
i hope you're you're talking to me i'm
kevin shelton
okay that was the dave i was going to
call next okay wonderful thank you um i
appreciate uh
you listening to me today i am in
opposition of sp 26.
um if you make i'll read what i have
prepared and i will send it to you folks
um i'm kevin shelton i'm speaking in
opposition of sb 26 i'm a resident of
woodsville
for the last 35 years
additionally my wife and i own property
both in north haverhill
and in
woodsville
as well as run
a business here
we've raised our family and have been
involved in the community
uh committees from economic development
to being a school board member for 10
years i invested in our community
as a whole
14 months ago
i was hired as the administrator here at
woodsville fire district
as you know there's been an agreement in
place between the town of haverhill and
woodsville on returning monies to
woodsville for highways since 1990.
this has been amicably amended twice
since being created
with the purpose of sparing woodsville
precinct residents and businesses the
burden of paying for two highway
departments as woodsville has operated
its own since the late 1880s
there has been there has been and is a
disagreement on the funding of road
monies between the two parties this is a
local issue and should not be resolved
with all due respect in concord
the woodsville precinct commissioners
voted formally at their last meeting
that they were opposed to this bill
and i know as you've heard today that
there's two two of the five select board
members are in opposition of it as well
through the precincts attorney
they've reached out to the town to have
a meeting on road funding
um and this really needs time to play
out they they need to get together
the second part of the bill
as amended is not relevant
woodsville fire district is fully
complying with having the necessary
audits they're being conducted by
plaudzik and sanderson
uh three years are completed i know that
was an earlier question
and 2018 and 19 are near completion
we have also as a district contracted
with project for 2020
that work will begin as soon as 19 is
done
and i hope that 20 is completed
certainly by the beginning of july
i would argue that the language
at the end of this should not be tied to
any bill as it's an add-on
and should apply to all towns and
districts equally throughout the state
and should not single out one community
um
i
before i close i i
in the 14 months that i've been here
i today was the second time that i've
heard of electrical sales
to
another state
the
water and light enterprise company
serves the precinct of woodsville
it extends electricity
up 135 north to monroe
monroe road in the town of bath
and it serves
the
south on route 10
encompasses the grafton county complex
as well as a short loop there for
electricity
there is
and has been
in my 14 months here
zero sales of power electricity to
anywhere but new hampshire
we buy power it comes from green
mountain
powers transmission lines which comes in
from vermont
it is fed from the north and the south
and wherever else
but there are no sales occurring here uh
through
water and light
to any other place and i'm not certain
where where that's coming from
additionally um and i would be happy to
share the audits with anyone that would
like me to send them to them
there has not been um
in the audits any commingling of money
from the highway to these other
enterprise funds and
and the audit will show that um so
um
in closing i i thank you for listening
to me i would ask you not to support sb
26 and not be bullied into voting for it
this is a local issue and it needs to be
resolved at the local level
thank you thank you are there any
questions from members of the committee
saying thank you
thank you
i see that representative vlad is
finished up with his committee work
and i would like to ask him to briefly
testify i believe in opposition to the
bill
well thank you very much uh
representative graham can you hear me
uh we're here
okay good even though i'm across the
hallway
um i would like to thank uh the
the committee for uh hearing my
testimony today for the record my name
is rick ladd ladd
i live in haverhill new hampshire not
haverhill massachusetts haverhill new
hampshire
i'm a recent
person to haverhill new hampshire we
moved down here in 2004 from alaska
where we lived 25 years
there however
my family eight year generations back
founded the town of haverhill new
hampshire
and so i have a lot of ties to this
community i have chaired the select
board in haverhill
um during 2009 very active on the select
board of that time i've also chaired the
haverhill corner commission which deals
with the water system there very active
in local uh affairs
representative ebel asked some questions
earlier about the history of
the uh
road system in woodsville i did have the
same question and i asked uh benoit
pelletier who works in the office
of legislative research here and he gave
me a report about a year ago and the
first issue that appears is in 1877.
then it goes 1887 1893 1899 a year after
the spanish-american war
1913 and then we get up to the years
that we're more involved with and i'd
like to speak to that just very quickly
and briefly
in 1990 representative paul lamont
put forward a bill
it was hb 1138 which dealt with the
woodsville road system and how monies
that were paid by woodsville folks and
haverhill folks for the highway budget
up to 20
would be used to support the system in
woodsville so it went back to 1990.
then sb 75 came about in 2009
that was put forth when i was asked the
selectmen up there and chairing the
select board at the time but i also want
to mention to you that the other
individuals that co-sponsored this bill
and sponsored this bill
was senator
deb reynolds out of plymouth whom i know
well and represented paul ingerbritson
who comes from pike one of the areas
within haverhill which is not part of
woodsville there are districts within
haverhill that have their own boards for
various tasks be it water be it fire be
it planting haverhill corner where i
live currently
and then you have north haverhill pike
and you have mountain lakes is and
woodsville
north haverhill haverhill corner
mountain lakes are primarily residential
oriented
our revenues and our income especially
if you look at meals and rooming rooms
income tax that stuff it all comes out
of woodsville
and so um there are also some uh uh
bills in the past which we should be
aware of before we get to 4 414 hb414
or to the uh omnibus bill we had last
year we've had memorandum of
understanding signed by both the
commissioners in woodsville and the
select board dating back to 1990
1995 and then there was a proposal to
the first amendment of the mou
in uh
prior to 2009
in 2009
when we worked with both boards to
develop this distribution funding
formula which is currently in law
both boards unanimously agreed to the
distribution formula in fact that's been
the way
that all legislation referencing the
distribution formula has occurred
it's been unanimously agreed upon by all
those that are participating i might add
that one of those select board members
that
was living in woodsville at that time in
2009 is now living down the street from
me in haverhill corner
when we were on the board at that time
and i was on that board we never thought
of ourselves as i'm from woodsville i'm
from mountain lakes or i'm from north
haverhill or haverhill corner
we represented all of haverhill
so when we made a decision we made a
decision in the best uh the betterment
of all the whole good of the town we did
that also when we changed how fire
departments were funded
we used to fund all our fire departments
three of them have corner
north haverhill and woodsville by the
precinct voters in those areas but
there's a lot of haverhill not in those
three areas
and back before 2009 or so the people
outside these precincts were not paying
for fire coverage at all
so we changed that so the town now
assesses everybody for fire departments
and the money was then distributed to
those individual precinct departments
and yes we do have a town fire
department now that was recently done by
way of war arctic but the first time
the
haverhill corner folks were asked to
support the new town
fire department they absolutely said no
we don't want anything to do with it we
need to see a long-range plan as far
what are the costs going to be how our
fire insurance is going to be affected
all that well the same issue is now
occurring with the roads
we have woodsville which is much
different than the rest of the community
whichville is the commercial center
woodsville has sewer
water sidewalks we don't have that
except in one location in north
haverhill
along route 10.
so the the cost of maintaining these
roads when we're dealing with water
under the roads when we're dealing with
sewer sewer our course are going to have
to be more for those eight miles of
roads in woodsville than the rest where
it's dirt or gravel or pavement
and but we all see and share the same
need to have good transportation
throughout the entire community
we've when we went back in 2009 and
looked at this distribution formula i
also asked at that time the town manager
mr glenn english who is an excellent
town manager and has the techno
technical skills to produce a fiscal
report i asked him to put together a
long
a plan which shows where are our monies
really being used for because at that
time many people said well our police
department's always hanging out in
woodsville so all our dollars are being
spent in woodsville when we did that
analysis for all our departments it came
out a wash for the entire town
woodsworth was not receiving any more
than any other location within the
community
we also know in looking at projections
for where we're going in the next five
or ten years
the tax base is definitely going to be
in woodsville
and you you have places like walmart
there now
our meals and rooms tax our restaurants
our hotel motel lodging is up there in
woodsville
and i see the revenues coming into
woodsville being much higher than that
at the rest of the community but what
the rest of the community is residential
and as with any large municipality or
municipality of around five thousand uh
people in it you're going to have
certain areas which are residential in
certain areas the more urban and have
urban residential yes but they are more
oriented towards commercial business
which i don't think there's too many
days that go by that i don't don't drive
up into woodsville to do my shopping
so going on down here when hb414 came up
in 2020
um both boards met with rep senator
gaida and myself and we were discussing
what do we need to do with this there
was agreement on one issue now some
people said though well that that
nothing came out from that first meeting
yes it did
we have highway money which goes to
woodsville that comes out of the
operating budget for the community you
know that
you've heard the split but there's also
highway block money revenue which comes
down from the state from d.o.t to
municipalities
and because it goes to municipalities
not to precincts or districts then the
share which goes down to woodsville
comes by way of the town and is
distributed out we have been dispersing
that money not out not in the same
manner that the state disperses the
money to the municipalities so there was
agreement that we should use the same
process the same formula as the state
sends money to the
to the municipalities from this
municipality haverhill to the fire
district woodsville there was agreement
now there was no agreement in regard to
some of the other issues but i know and
you know that the first time you sit
down at a meeting
you have to really work hard roll the
sleeves up and it takes a while to get
there it took us a long time to get
there in regard to
having the whole town take ownership in
how we fund our fire departments but we
did that
now that we're in the fire department
business and and going that direction
the only reason why primarily
haverhill corner has opted to join the
no the town fire department which
consists only of north haverhill is that
the fun money that was supporting our
fire department came down from everybody
raising revenue in this town through the
to through the town
well with the threat that we may not
receive that money obviously the the 190
uh some odd people in haverhill corner
said well we we will we'll join that
department they did by a very close vote
so there
this there are issues that we need to
look at it takes time for change
but the plan that to move forward with
roads what is the plan
immediately following when the town
takes over the woodsville roads what
happens to the labor force within woods
will what about their benefits what
about their retirement how are they
going to be taken care of is there any
guarantee they're going to still be
there what happens in terms of
a long-range plan in terms of the
the maintenance of all the other issues
water department in in in woodsville
what happens to the sewer that comes
from north haverhill down into
uh
uh woodsville where it's treated and and
taken care of there
uh
i think the folks in woodsville as the
people in haverhill corner we're looking
for yes we want to we want to work
towards all being one town working
together and which we try to do
but we need to see the plan
how's that going to impact our our local
expenses our assets our revenues and if
that can be all laid out then people are
willing to sit down and talk i don't
believe that's all been laid out to the
woodsville fire district this is a very
divisive issue
and there is litigation going on right
now which is a shame that each of us in
woodsville and the rest of the town are
having to use our local revenues to
fight each other this has to stop uh it
just cannot continue in regard to the
audit
i have spoken with the manager that's
been recently hired who comes back comes
to us from industry here in new
hampshire
and has a good understanding how to
manage how to administrate uh units such
as the woodsworth uh departments
which have been now merged into one
under one roof which he manages and
there the first several years yes errors
have been found they found errors in
other areas of haverhill when we had our
audits done for our annual audit they
found errors and piermonts too which
piermont went through a disastrous time
several years back
so these things happen but it's not
fraudulent
and nothing has been proven to be
fraudulent in the audit the audit should
be done sometime later this summer
and
i think it's very premature
to be acting on a bill such as this
without having a good strong knowledge
of what that audit has netted us
and we don't have that yet so i i'm not
supportive of this bill i think the bill
has a lot of areas which
need really a good stiff look at
there's areas in which the distribution
formula was agreed by all in the
community
and by that i mean all those lived in
haverhill
and it's um it's it's worked
uh now there might be some disagreement
as to what is the definition of a net
operating budget versus the highway
operating budget that could be
easily resolved by just putting
definition into the statute
also it could be made you know a statute
could be had amended somewhere along the
way i don't know if this is the time to
do it perhaps not but a statute could be
amended stating that any future changes
are may be done by the two boards the
commissioners and the select board
working together without having to have
the approval of the general court
there's a lot of things that can be done
here and that is why we need to really
take some time here and i urge this
committee
to take some time and looking at this
this has been highly contentious down in
in the community
we've had this before when it came to
our schools
folks in haverhill corner didn't like
the idea taking the haverhill academy
out of haverhill corner
and taking the high school up to
woodsville so it's nothing new we sort
of got getting out of that old cultural
thinking and we're becoming a town in
terms of our schools haverhill is an old
community much like conway used to be
with their precincts we're getting there
we're moving there but we have to move
there with uh
with foresight and with a good look at
what we're going to be five to ten years
down the road we want to move to
something that's going to not cost us
out of the business
we want to move that we have something
that's more efficient
and we need to work there together so we
all have ownership in it right now by
the state making a decision
on this issue
we're we're just mandating hey roll this
is how things will happen
there's no ownership that's going to
come about that and we really run the
risk
of having one precinct trying to become
their own municipality
article 24 in 2020 which was on our town
report
asked the voters whether they wanted to
take over ownership of the highway
system in woodsville
contingent upon
the woodsville residence
agreeing
when it went to the woodsville residence
for the agreement the vote was 52-0
not to join haverhill at this time
there was no plan paralleling that
request or that article
so in conclusion i know i've talked
quite a bit here i'm willing to take
questions but i urge you
to go cautiously on this bill thank you
very much thank you are there any
questions from members of the community
seeing none thank you representative
vlad
um i'm looking for
um
at one point there was a representative
from the dra
um
on the attendee list
if there is somebody from
the bra
i would like to hear from you at this
point
um
let's frame
mr
jerry
yes sir
you are
with
are you with the dra yes i am uh my name
is james just talk a little bit about
the audit of what you know
and i'm going to preface this all by a
request that you send whatever
parts of the completed id audit you can
to members of the community
okay well we uh certainly first thank
you for uh entertaining
me and allowing me to speak on this
important legislation
uh there are there are you know two
parts of the legislation i'm not going
to comment as the dra takes no position
on the first part of the legislation
the the second part of the legislation
is really what we care about and it is
really because rsa
4131a states that financial audits play
a fundamentally vital role in helping to
preserve the integrity of the public
finance functions by maintaining
citizens confidence in their elected
leaders
properly performed audits provide
independent assurance that financial
information presented is reliable
because of this new hampshire law
mandates that all municipalities with
populations of greater than 750 conduct
an annual audit
now over the last 20 years the
woodsville fire district attempted to
complete just one audit and that was in
that audit was not completed because
officials in the district refused to
turn over the necessary documents
over a dispute about confidentiality
since 2014 the district elected numerous
auditors and made statements both to the
public and to the dra that they had
audited financials however after we
investigated the situation we realized
that the locally elected auditor
never actually performed an audit and
the audited financial statements they
claimed to have were nothing more than
unaudited financial statements
the first time we actually saw a
movement towards completing an audit was
when sb 414 was introduced last year
this bill which passed the house and
senate imposed the same penalties that
this bill does for not completing their
audits in a timely fashion
as a result of the pressure put on the
district in 2020 they engaged the firmer
plazak and sanderson to complete at
least five years of audits to date they
have completed three of these audits
these audits reveal numerous violations
of state statutes
these include violations of rsa 32 the
municipal budget law rsa 33 the
municipal finance act and additional
violations of rsa 41.
some of the potential violations or
violations actually include taking out
loans without first getting
approval from the voters under new
hampshire law you're supposed to get 60
approval from the voters
uh they took out loans without getting
any support from the electorate filing
incomplete or misleading forms with the
dra that concealed these loans
and making risky investments that are
contrary to state law
the dra is in the process of further
investigating these potential violations
this includes commingling of funds the
audits also
detail concerns that are not under the
purview of the dra one such example
which has been talked about was a
district falsely reporting to the new
hampshire retirement system over an
11-year period about an employee that
they had misca mis
mis categorized
in addition to the
numerous violations of state statutes
the audit detailed how the district had
no meaningful internal controls in place
that would help minimize the risk of
fraud or human error in fact the audit
states the following
based upon the results of the audit
procedures and observations made during
the audit
we noted the district has a lack of
internal control and direction regarding
the accounting system in overall
fiscal mismanagement
we have significant concerns that
without the passage of senate bill 26
the district will have little incentive
to complete the two years of remaining
audits
we believe the potential penalties
imposed
by last year's sb 414 is what forced
woodsville water and light hand
and
in 2020 and without that the three years
of audits we now have would not have
been completed
therefore the dra believes is imperative
those penalties contained in sb 26 are
enacted if the legislature wishes the
dra to have a meaningful and effective
way to enforce compliance with rsa 4131a
and just on on a final note
i'm i'm assuming i misheard
a couple of speakers because i believe
they said
there was absolutely no way
there was any commingling of funds and
the audit showed that
uh where of course on i'm looking at
page 46 of and i just grabbed the 2016
audit
uh under the
compliance with state statutes payment
in lieu of taxes from proprietary fund
surpluses we identified three transfers
of 15 000
each made from accumulated fund balances
of water fund electric fund and sewer
fund to the district's general fund as a
payment in lieu of taxes these transfers
were made
contrary to the provision of rsa 3829
water funds and rsa 149 110 sewer fund
what those statutes with those rsa do
was prevent the co-mingling of funds
which their own auditors said they did
so again i must have misheard them when
they said there wasn't that was not
going on
um i will now uh certainly open up for
any questions you may have
i do have
those audits online
or
not
uh i i don't believe we we the dra does
it's online we do not have those audits
online but they are publicly available
we send you the three years of audits
that i have uh to you sir if if you
could
[Music]
send them to me as chairman and you can
find my
my email
and any member who wants it i can
forward it on to you
but i think that for some of us
um probably don't want three
um
large volumes of audience
but i can hit them up two people i think
that some of us are going to want to
look at them before we make a
final decision on what to do with this
bill
that's not a problem
thank you mr chairman mr gary
do you um
does the dira determine whether any of
these
or is it your purview to determine
whether any of these
issues are criminal
or just
a lack of knowledge on
on the
part of the people
who've
put themselves in place in the
management positions
yeah thank you thank you for your
question uh we only determine
what
uh violates the laws that we deal with
which is mainly the municipal budget act
the missile finance act
and let's say 41. we do not assign
criminality to that that would be
the department of justice that would
would handle that that is not something
the dra is involved with
thank you
any further questions
seeing none thank you very much for
sticking around and answering our
questions
um i do have
senator geider you had your hand up a
while a minute ago
if you want to speak i will give you a
second
bite at the apple for about three
minutes
mr chairman you you were blocked as far
as as i was being signed in by your
uh your zoom controller so i'm not sure
what you said
um you had your hand up yeah and i was
willing to give you a second shot at the
apple
um but very very briefly
thank you mr chairman and i appreciate
the uh
the indulgence
very
quickly here you are as a state
legislative committee
okay
digging into details of what is clearly
a local matter
and the point i'm trying to make and
asking you to support
senate bill 26
is this is not where this committee
belongs this is not a state issue of
funding it's not a state issue of
transportation or public works
the legislature has no place here
passing this law
will harm nothing
it will in fact facilitate moving
forward
because at that point
there will be no state law
preempting the ability of local agencies
to move forward and having to bring this
before a state legislature whose duties
are to the state and not to the if you
will
assessing
funding requirements on local
communities for the sake of other local
communities
so with great respect for the duties
that you fulfill in covering our state's
highways
this is a law that needs to go away so
that the problem can in fact be solved
in the words of representative lad
dealing with this since 2004
trying to change it can't happen
trying to change or alter that
relationship cannot happen
with this statute in place as it is
hence the origin of senate bill 26 the
passage of which will in fact enable
the communities to work forward
constructively with no blockade
established by state law thank you mr
chairman
yes thank you mr thank you senator
um you said that there really is no
role for the state here but
one of the things we heard was that uh
a source of the conflict is how state
highway fund
revenue sharing to
to haverhill get split up among the
different towns and
at different precincts and um
that does seem to be
a state issue and one of the ones that
we certainly dealt with in this
committee
the you know the the local tax portion
of it
i i think it's just a wash i mean if uh
if haverhill wants to take their money
and
with villa takes their money then you
know that's
that's how this village uh precinct
system works
really is no change there the only
change is how they deal with the money
that comes from the state
with all due respect representative
that is not correct
the highway block grant money is in fact
distributed fully in accord with state
law the percentages based on population
and so forth mileage there is no change
that this in no way impacts the
distribution of the hobby block grant
this bill only impacts and requires
raising and appropriating local funds by
one community and requiring by state law
that those funds be given to another
community
so there's no impact whatsoever on the
highway block grants thank you
thank you senator
i have no other hands raised for anybody
wishing to speak
um
i will close the public hearing on
senate
bill 6.
um
thank everybody for sticking around for
two hours of testimony
as as many of you know i had hoped to
execute this bill today
however
given the fact that i've asked for the
audit
to forward it to us
um jennifer butcher had a lot of
statistics she was going to send us
uh
mr clay and mr shelton both had said
they were going to send a written
testimony i think that we need to take
some time
look through all of this information
before we make a final decision rather
than jump into it today
um
i know some of us are probably ready
to say let's finish this and get it over
with but i think we need to do it right
um
our
um executive session on this bill
will be on the night wednesday the 19th
for that
it will be in the hybrid
situation
um
i will work with the
uh ranking member on a good time whether
it's morning or afternoon okay and we'll
talk about i was just asking
um
so i think that it will remove all of us
to look through all of the information
we already have
look through some of the history and
look through the information that will
be forthcoming
i think that in order to do that we'll
come to the right decision
and again
we will have four choices
you know
pass it kill it
amend it or
retain it work on it for the next few
weeks a
few months so
that those are the options that we will
look at on the night
representative people's hand up as
always
oh
um i wondered if representative ladd
could share the research that he had ols
do for him on the legislative history
um
you can find his email and ask him for
it
okay
i see i see it i see him um and the
other thing is i just was trying to
understand what the litigation was and
maybe he can tell us about that too
did you hear the request
yes i did uh representative graham
um yes i do have the uh communication i
got from benoit pelletier i will forward
that on to you mr chairman you can
distribute it to your committee
um also in regard to the litigation uh
the i i'm not
really part of this anymore however i
can tell you that there's a sizable
amount of dollar that's being spent by
both parties on this and
of course
we finished the hearing on this bill i
don't want to get too much
in depth on things that were said
in the uh
in the hearing and because we're not in
executive session either so
we're kind of outside the realms of our
boundaries here uh what we should or
should not be doing
but the request for
the um
history is legitimate
any
thing else from any members of the
committee
on what the way forward is
this is one thing representative i
hardly concur with your decision i think
we need to take our time on this this
i just wouldn't want to i don't think
i'd make a good decision today if i hit
the phone
our decisions are always good okay yeah
i i'm just speaking for myself
but i think that there's a lot of head
shaking that i think a lot of people
want to look at
um
do our due diligence to make sure we've
come to the right decision
um
and another two weeks isn't gonna kill
whatever impetus there is for for this
bill of lack thereof
any other questions from members of the
committee to me about the way forward um
i
as i said in my last email there will be
at least two days of sessions
in uh the first week of june
we've got all the senate bills to handle
so
stay tuned for
you know date time and price and all
that stuff in the calendar
and with
that we are adjourned
until the 19th of may thank you all for
sticking with it all day
thank you